GOOD MORNING THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR JOINING US OUR REGULARLY
SCHEDULED ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON
BUSINESS AND PROFESSIONS A FEW
HOUSEKEEPING ITEMS.
THE FOLLOWING BILLS HAVE BEEN
POLLS -- BY THE AUTHORS FILE
ITEM NUMBER SIX WAS IT SB FOUR
SEVENTY FIVE BY SENATOR SKINNER
AND FILE ITEM NUMBER ELEVEN SB
SIX SEVENTY NINE BY SENATOR
BATES AGAIN.
A TWO BILLS US AUTHOR POLLS AS
BEFORE SEVENTY FIVE AND SB. SIX
SEVENTY NINE WE ALSO HAVE A ONE
BILL ON CONSENT BUT WE ARE I CAN
QUORUM AT THIS MOMENT BUT NOTICE
THE PRESENCE OF BOTH MEMBERS.
ON BOTH SIDES OF THE AISLE SO WE
WILL BEGIN AS A SUB COMMITTEE
BUT I UNDERSTAND THAT THERE HAS
BEEN A KIND GENTLEMEN'S
AGREEMENT.
AND SAID -- WILL THEN BEGIN AND
OUT OF ORDER AT TWO UNDER THIS
AGREEMENT WHICH IS FILE ITEM
NUMBER FOUR SB THREE EIGHTY BY A
THREE EIGHTY FIVE BY SENATOR
JONES.
SAID A JONES.
YET AGAIN MIRACULOUSLY YOUR BILL
ENJOYS AND DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION ON BOTH SIDES OF
THE AISLE YET AGAIN.
PLEASE FEEL FREE PRESENT
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND THE
THE MEMBERS THAT ARE PRESENT I
APPRECIATE YOUR ATTENTION.
I AM I WAS JUST SLIGHTLY
DISAPPOINTED THAT I DON'T GET TO
PRESENT TO THE ENTIRE COMMITTEE
BUT I CAN COME BACK LATER WHEN
EVERYBODY ELSE GETS YOU IF YOU
WANT ME -- TO I'D LIKE TO START
BY ACCEPTING THE AMENDMENTS
RECOMMENDED ON PAGES FIVE SIX
AND SEVEN OF THE COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
FOR COMMITTEE STAFF. FOR A
MAKING THE BILL -- EVEN BETTER
AND AND SHORTER AND EASIER TO
UNDERSTAND ACTUALLY FROM WHAT I
UNDERSTAND SO -- I'D REALLY LIKE
TO THANK YOU AND YOUR COMMITTEE
STAFF AND SENATE BILL THREE
EIGHTY FIVE MAKE SEVERAL UPDATES
TO THE PRIVATE INVESTIGATOR
ACTION IMPROVE CONSUMER
PROTECTIONS.
MAINLY THIS BILL UPDATES THE
PHYSICAL PRIVATE INVESTIGATOR
LICENSE BY CREATING A PORTABLE
LICENSE THE CONTAINS INFORMATION
NECESSARY FOR A CONSUMER TO
VERIFY A LICENSE.
SUCH AS A PICTURE OF THE LICENSE
AND THE LICENSE IT LICENSES
EXPIRATION DATE.
THIS BILL ALSO BRINGS CONFORMITY
TO VIOLATIONS OF THE ACT BY
REMOVING A DUPLICATIVE AND
CONTRADICTORY SECTION OF CODE.
REGULATING UNLICENSED PRACTICE
OF PRIVATE INVESTIGATION FINALLY
WHAT THE COMMITTEES THAT A MAN'S
I'VE ACCEPTED.
WE WILL BE CORRECTING A SIMPLE
ACCIDENTAL EMISSION EXEMPTING
PEACE OFFICERS FROM TRAINING
AROUND -- POWER TO ARREST AND
USE OF FIREARMS WITH ME TODAY
HAVE FRANCIE FROM THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION LICENSE
INVESTIGATORS HERE TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS.
IF YOU SO CHOOSE TO ASK ANY.
THANK YOU ASKED FOR YOUR RIVAL
THANK YOU VERY MUCH PLEASE.
GOOD MORNING SENATORS GOOD
MORNING CHAIR OB COULD JUST
QUICKLY AND THE PAST PRESENT AND
THE AND THE CURRENT LEGISLATION
SHARE FOR THE GOVERNMENT AFFAIRS
COMMITTEE WE URGE YOUR VOTE AND
SB THREE EIGHTY FIVE I THINK
SENATOR JONES SAID EVERYTHING IT
NEEDED TO BE SAID.
AND THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
WISHING TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT AT
THIS TIME.
SEE NO MENACES IN SUPPORT ANY
WITNESSES WISHING TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION NO WITNESSES
OPPOSITION ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
NO QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
CAN MEMBERS AT THIS TIME AND
WILL TAKE UP THIS ITEM -- WHEN
WE HAVE TO STOP IS A QUORUM
THANK YOU IS SURE THANK YOU
COLLEAGUES APPRECIATE YOUR
ATTENTION?
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THEN MOVING BACK IN ORDER WHICH
IS FILE ITEM NUMBER TWO SB. ONE
FIFTY NINE BY SENATOR WIENER
.
IN THIS IS CENTER WE'RE SENATOR
WIENER WELCOME WILL ALLOW UP TO
THREE MINUTES OF TESTIMONY IN
TOTAL FOR THEIR WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT AND WILL OF COURSE DO
THE SAME. FOR THREE MINUTES IN
TOTAL FOR WITNESSES WISHING TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION [inaudible]
GREAT.
I THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
CHAIRMAN I THANK YOU AND THE
COMMITTEE FOR WORKING.
WITH US ON THE BILL -- REGARDING
THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS
OUTLINED IN THE ANALYSIS -- WE
WILL -- EXCEPT THOSE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS -- I DO WANT TO KNOW
AS CHAIR AND I HAVE DISCUSSED --
THAT THERE IS SOME INTERACTION
BETWEEN THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS --
AND THE AMENDMENTS THAT WERE
PLACED IN THE BILL BY THE SENATE
BUSINESS AND PROFESSIONS.
I COMMITTEE -- AND THOSE WILL
NEED TO BE IRONED OUT SO IT'S
VERY IMPORTANT TO ME THAT BOTH
COMMITTEES BE SATISFIED -- WITH
THE BILL -- SO AS CHAIR AND I
DISCUSSED -- GOING FORWARD -- I
I WILL WOULD LIKE TO TRY TO
CONVENE I HAVE BOTH KIDNEYS WORK
TOGETHER WITH ME -- AND FIGURE
THIS OUT BEFORE THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE BUT WE
ARE -- ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS ARE TODAY.
I THANK YOU -- COLLEAGUES ARE
SENATE BILL -- ONE FIFTY NINE
WILL HELP US EXPAND ACCESS TO
TWO VERY POWERFUL ANTI -- IT --
IT -- HIV PROFOUND AS EXPOSURE
PROPHYLAXIS AND POST EXPOSURE
PROPHYLAXIS OR PROP IMPACT.
OUR PRACTICE IS A ONCE A DAY
PILL THAT ARE REDUCES RISK OF
HIV INFECTION BY AS MUCH AS 99% --
AND PAT IS A A TWENTY EIGHT DAY
COURSE -- FOR WHEN A AND
SITUATION WHERE SOMEONE BELIEVES
THAT THEY'VE BEEN EXPOSED OR HAS
POTENTIALLY BEEN EXPOSED TO HIV --
VIS -- TOOLS ARE ESSENTIAL -- IN
OUR EFFORT TO AND INSIDE B. --
INFECTIONS ON UNFORTUNATELY --
THE UPTAKE OF PROP IN PARTICULAR --
HAS BEEN NOT WHAT WE WANT
PARTICULARLY IN COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR -- BUT REALLY OUTSIDE OF
OUR METROPOLITAN AREAS AND WE
ARE STILL SEEING PEOPLE GET
INFECTED AND THERE ARE MANY MANY
PEOPLE -- IN CALIFORNIA WHO
COULD BENEFIT FROM PROP WHO ARE
NOT ON IT AND THERE ARE VARIOUS
BARRIERS -- TO PROP ON AND WE
ARE ADDRESSING TWO OF THEM IN
THIS BILL -- THE FIRST IS THAT.
THERE ARE STILL INSURANCE
COMPANIES THAT ARE REQUIRING
PRIOR AUTHORIZATIONS FOR PROP.
AND FOR PAP -- IT FOR PEPPERS
PARTICULARLY OUTRAGEOUS WHEN
THIS HAPPENS BECAUSE YOU HAVE TO
GO ON THE POP WITHIN SEVENTY TWO
HOURS OF EXPOSURE -- IN ORDER
FOR IT TO BE A FACTOR -- AND
WE'VE HAD SITUATIONS WHERE
INSURANCE COMPANIES HAVE --
REQUIRED PRIOR AUTHORIZATIONS
FOR THAT SEVENTY TWO HOUR PERIOD
WHICH IS OUTRAGEOUS -- BUT FOR
PROP AS WELL -- WHEN SOMEONE IS
AT RISK -- THEY SHOULD BE ABLE
TO GET ACCESS TO PROP.
QUICKLY AND NOT HAVE TO WAIT
TIMES A MONTH FOR A PRIOR
AUTHORIZATION SO THE BILL WILL
BAN PRIOR AUTHORIZATIONS FOR
PROBLEM TOP -- THE OTHER --
BARRIER THAT THE BILL ADDRESSES
IS IN TERMS OF HOW TO ACCESS THE
HEALTH CARE PROFESSIONALS WHO
CAN PROVIDE.
A PROP AND TOP -- AND RIGHT NOW
YOU HAVE TO GO THROUGH A
POSITION -- WHEN I WENT ON THE
PROJECT I WENT THROUGH MY
POSITION AND IT WAS A GREAT
EXPERIENCE AND A VERY
KNOWLEDGEABLE AND NON JUDGMENTAL
POSITION?
UNFORTUNATELY NOT EVERYONE HAS
THE SAME EXPERIENCE -- ALTHOUGH
MANY DOCTORS ARE INCREDIBLY GOOD
ABOUT TALKING ABOUT ALL AND
ADDRESSING SEXUAL HEALTH THERE
ARE STILL PHYSICIANS WHO ARE NOT
AND WE STILL HEAR STORIES OF
PATIENTS.
TO GO TO SEE THE DOCTOR AND ASK
FOR PROP -- AND AND THE RESPONSE
IS -- JUDGMENTS AND TRYING TO
ARGUE WITH THEM AND AND THEN
THEY'VE COURSES SHRINK INTO A
CALL AND GO AWAY AND AND I'M NOT
GOING ON THE PROP.
IN ADDITION WE HAVE A PHYSICIAN
SHORTAGE AND IT IS STILL COMMON
FOR PEOPLE TO STRUGGLE -- TO GET
AN APPOINTMENT IT COULD TAKE
WEEKS OR MONTHS TO GET AN
APPOINTMENT AND WHEN PEOPLE ARE
RESTING NEED ACCESS NOW -- SO
THE BILL WILL ALLOW --
PHARMACISTS -- TO PROVIDE PROP
OR PATH WITHOUT A PHYSICIAN'S US
A PRESCRIPTION IN THE CASE OF
OUR PRODUCT THE PHARMACIST UNDER
THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS WILL BE
ABLE TO PROVIDE THE FIRST SIXTY
DAYS WORTH -- AND THEN THERE
AFTER A PERSON WILL HAVE TO GO
INTO A PHYSICIAN'S CARE AND GET
THE REQUIRED BLOOD WORK AND SO
FORTH I SAID THIS BILL WITH
RESPECT TO PROP DOES NOT CUT
POSITIONS OUT.
ASSEMBLY ALLOWS SOMEONE TO
QUICKLY GO TO THEIR NEIGHBORHOOD
PHARMACY THE PHARMACIST WILL
HAVE TO RECEIVE TRAINING -- GET
STARTED -- AND THEN AFTER A
PERIOD OF TIME ENTER A
PHYSICIAN'S CARE -- TO BE ABLE
TO CONTINUE.
SO WE THINK THAT THE BILL --
STRIKES THE RIGHT BALANCE -- WE
HAVE BROAD SUPPORT -- FROM --
FROM THE HIV ADVOCACY COMMUNITY
EVERY CREDIBLE HIV ORGANIZATION
IS SUPPORTING -- THIS BILL -- AS
WELL AS MANY OTHERS -- AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
NOW WITH ME TODAY -- OR FEW
WITNESSES CAROLINE -- TO WITH
UCSF -- POSITION WITH YOU SEE US
OFF -- CRAIG PULLS OVER WITH A
PL A HEALTH.
I COULD HAWKINS OF PHARMACISTS
WITHOUT WHICH THE PHARMACY.
AND ALSO WITH US TODAY IT'S
TAMMY MARTIN -- WITH THE QUALITY
CALIFORNIA THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH AND AGAIN WE WILL
ALLOW UP TO THREE MINUTES IN
TOTAL SO I SEE THAT THERE ARE
FOUR DIVISIONS PERHAPS YOU CAN.
BE AS CONCISE AS POSSIBLE PLEASE
FEEL FREE TO PRESENT WHENEVER
YOU'RE READY THANK YOU.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER'S -- I GET THE
DISTINGUISHED ASSEMBLY MEMBERS
MY NAME IS DOCTOR CAROLYN TO AN
HIV SPECIALIST PHYSICIAN IN SAN
FRANCISCO AND THE CLINICAL
DIRECTOR OF THE NATIONAL PREP
LINE AND PIPELINE.
THANK YOU FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY.
TWO WEEKS AGO THE U. S.
PREVENTIVE SERVICES TASK FORCE
K. PREP A GRADE A RATING ITS
HIGHEST.
BASING THE RECOMMENDATION ON AN
IN DEPTH ANALYSIS OF THE
POTENTIAL BENEFITS AND HARMS A
PREP AS WELL AS A COMPREHENSIVE
ASSESSMENT OF THE BALANCE OF
EVIDENCE.
IN SHORT THE TASK FORCE
CONCLUDED WITH HIGH CERTAINTY
THAT THE NET BENEFIT A PREP TO
REDUCE THE RISK OF HIV FOR THOSE
AT ELEVATED RISK IS SUBSTANTIAL.
SB ONE FIVE NINE IF ENACTED
COULD HELP CALIFORNIA MAKE
EXTRAORDINARY STRIDES TO
SUBSTANTIALLY IMPROVE TIMELY
ACCESS TO PREP AND PAT FOR THE
THOUSANDS OF ITS RESIDENTS WHO
ARE AT RISK FOR HIV.
PHARMACISTS ARE AN INTEGRAL
COMPONENT OF OUR STATE
HEALTHCARE DELIVERY SYSTEM AS
THEY ARE HIGHLY TRAINED CLINICAL
PROFESSIONALS WHO HOLDEN
UNPARALLELED UNDERSTANDING OF
PHARMACOTHERAPY EASE.
PHARMACISTS ARE ALSO A TRUSTED
CORNERSTONE FOR HIGH QUALITY
PATIENT SERVICES IN ALMOST EVERY
COMMUNITY IN OUR STATE.
THEY ARE OFTEN A SOURCE OF
INFORMATION FOR INDIVIDUALS WHO
ARE NOT WELL CONNECTED TO A
PRIMARY CARE PROVIDER AND CAN
ALSO BE AN EFFECTIVE MEANS OF
LINKING SOMEONE TO CARE.
I RESPECTFULLY URGE MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE TO VOTE YES TO
PROVE TIMELY ACCESS TO TWO
HIGHLY EFFECTIVE SAFE HIV
PREVENTION INTERVENTIONS FOR
PERSONS WHO ARE MOST IN NEED.
THIS WILL HELP ADVANCE MORE
PATIENT CENTERED INTEGRATED AND
EFFICIENT HEALTHCARE DELIVERY
SYSTEM FOR CALIFORNIA THAT WILL
HOPEFULLY MOVE THE DIAL ON
ENDING THIS EPIDEMIC.
A GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE -- LIKE
CENTER WIENER SAID WE NOW HAVE
DAILY MEDICATIONS THAT CAN
PREVENT HIV YEAH WE STILL HAVE
NEARLY FIVE THOUSAND
CALIFORNIANS TO ACQUIRE HIV
EVERY YEAR.
PERHAPS HAS BEEN APPROVED FOR
NEARLY SEVEN YEARS AND STILL
LESS THAN 20% OF PEOPLE WHO
COULD BENEFIT FROM THE
MEDICATIONS ARE CURRENTLY TAKING
THAT.
CLEAR CLEARLY WHAT WE ARE DOING
NOW IS NOT WORKING WE NEED A
BOLD AND INNOVATIVE POLICY
SOLUTIONS TO ADDRESS THESE
BARRIERS AND PUT THESE
MEDICATIONS IN THE HANDS WHO
NEED THE MOST.
AND THAT'S WHY SB ONE FIVE NINE
IS THE FIRST IN THE NATION BILL
THAT WOULD ALLOW PHARMACISTS TO
FURNISH PAP AND A LIMITED COURSE
OF PREP WITHOUT A DOCTOR'S
PRESCRIPTION.
SIMILAR TO WHAT IT WHAT IS
ALREADY BEING DONE FOR THE LOCKS
ON BIRTH CONTROL AND OTHER
IMPORTANT MEDICATIONS.
THE BILL HAS BEEN CAREFULLY
CRAFTED TO PROTECT PATIENT
SAFETY AND ENSURE THAT CDC
GUIDELINES ARE FOLLOWED.
AND ENJOYS BROAD SUPPORT FROM
PHYSICIANS AND HIV SPECIALISTS
PARTICULARLY THOSE THAT
SPECIALIZE IN GOOD PROPER CARE.
SB ONE FIVE NINE IS AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR CALIFORNIA TO BE
A LEADER AND EXPANDING ACCESS TO
THESE LIFESAVING MEDICATIONS AND
I OR DRIVE A MISTER CHAIR
COMMITTEE MEMBER SIGN DOCTOR
KLEIN HOPKINS PHARMACIST OWNER
OF BUSH'S PHARMACY WHICH HAS
BEEN PART OF THE SACRAMENTO
COMMUNITY SINCE.
NINETEEN THIRTY THIS PHARMACY IS
BEEN FOCUSED ON THE HEALTH AND
WELLNESS OF SACRAMENTO RESIDENTS
FOR NEARLY NINETY YEARS WE KNOW
OUR PATIENTS AND FAMILY MEMBERS
BY NAME.
IT IS HEARTBREAKING FOR ME TO
DISCUSS HIV MEDICATIONS WITH A
NEWLY DIAGNOSED PERSON WHEN I
KNOW THAT THERE'S MEDICATION
AVAILABLE IN THE FORM OF CRAP
WHICH COULD HAVE PREVENTED THEIR
INFECTION OR PAT.
WHICH COULD HAVE STOPPED IT
AFTER THEY WERE EXPOSED THEY
JUST DIDN'T HAVE ACCESS TO IT
WHEN THEY NEEDED IT.
SB ONE FIFTY NINE BUILDS UPON
GAINES CALIFORNIA HAS MADE TO
INCREASE THE AVAIL THE
AVAILABILITY.
OF PREVENTATIVE MEDICATIONS AND
PRODUCTS TO PATIENTS BY ALLOWING
PHARMACISTS TO FURNISH IN
LIMITED QUANTITIES MEDICATIONS
PROVEN TO REDUCE THE SPREAD OF
HIV AND AIDS.
SB ONE FIFTY NINE WILL ALSO
INCREASE THE NUMBER OF HIV
TESTING SITES ACROSS THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA.
THERE BY EMPOWERING OUR CITIZENS
WITH THE KNOWLEDGE OF THEIR HIV
STATUS.
I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR
SUPPORT FOR THIS IMPORTANT
PUBLIC HEALTH DON'T.
THINK YOU AND YOU JUST CAN WE
SUMMARIZE SHIRT TAMMY MARTIN ON
BEHALF OF EQUALITY CALIFORNIA
PROUD COSPONSOR OF THE BILL --
HIGH PRIORITY FOR US AS PART OF
OUR ON GOING HIV PREVENTION WORK
IT'S A CRITICAL PUBLIC HEALTH
BILL AND WE RESPECTFULLY URGE
YOUR SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH TIME.
THIS NO WITNESSES WISHING TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT NAME AND
AFFILIATION IF YOU WISH TO DO SO.
THE FIRST NIGHT ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA RETAILERS ASSOCIATION
AND THE NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF
CHAIN DRUG STORES WE'RE SUPPORT
WE ARE VERY SUPPORTIVE VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE THE AMENDMENTS BUT DO
LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUE
DISCUSSIONS.
WE THINK THERE NEEDS TO BE SOME
CLARITY I WITH RESPECT TO
OVERALL PATIENT ACCESS TO PREP
AND PERHAPS EVEN ONCE THEY LEAVE
AND ARE NO LONGER ABLE TO ACCESS
THE PHARMACIST DIRECTLY -- AND
THEN WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
THERE'S COVERAGE FOR THAT AND
SOME OF THE NEW AMENDMENTS WE
CONTINUE TO WANT TO WORK ON SO
WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
THE AUTHOR BETTER IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING TIM VALDERRAMA WITH
THE WEATHERMAN GROUP ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA SOCIETY OF
HEALTH SYSTEM PHARMACISTS WERE
CO SPONSOR THE MEASURE IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
REBEKAH GONZALEZ NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN SUPPORT.
ANSWER GRAND WITH THE BOARD OF
PHARMACY IN SUPPORT.
COURTNEY WILL HAVE HERE SOME OF
THE SAN FRANCISCO AIDS
FOUNDATION CO SPONSOR IN SUPPORT.
AARON FOX LOS ANGELES LGBT SPAHN
THE LOS ANGELES LGBT CENTER CO
SPONSOR AND SUPPORT AND ALSO ON
BEHALF OF THE ACLU IN SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING PATTY ARMS FOR ON
BEHALF THE COUNTY HEALTH
EXECUTIVES ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT.
MARIA LOPEZ PROP PHARMACIST
MISSION WELLNESS COMMUNITY
PHARMACY IN SUPPORT.-MICHELLE RIVAS CALIFORNIA
PHARMACISTS ASSOCIATION
COSPONSORED TO PART.
MANY HERE WITH CALIFORNIA LIFE
SCIENCES SO HUGE AND SUPPORT.
HI JENNIFER SUMMERS WITH THE
MEDICAL BOARD OF CALIFORNIA WE
HAVE A TWEENER POSITION WHERE
SUPPORT OF AMENDED.
SO WE DO SUPPORT PHARMACIST
BEING ABLE TO DISPENSE PAP AS
WILL INCREASE ACCESS WHICH IS
IMPORTANT HOWEVER THE BOARD
BELIEVES THAT PREP BECAUSE IT
REQUIRES REGULAR MONITORING
TESTING HERE INSTEAD IS NOT
APPROPRIATE FOR PHARMACIST TO
INITIATE PROP.
WE DID HAVE A REQUEST AMENDMENTS
REGARDING PROTOCOLS BUT I
BELIEVE THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS
ADDRESS THAT ISSUE AND I KNOW
THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS ALSO DO
LIMIT PROP SO HAVE TO TAKE THIS
A BILL BACK TO OUR BOARD ARE
MORE BEING AUGUST BUT WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THE
AUTHOR.
ON THIS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES WISHING TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT CNN NOW
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION PLEASE
FEEL FREE TO COME UP TO THE
TABLE HERE.
AND WE WILL USE THE ALLOWED --
TO UP TO THREE MINUTES BUT WE
RAN INTO FOUR MINUTES SO WE'LL
GIVE -- WITNESSES UP TO FOUR
MINUTES TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION
SO FEEL FREE TO PLEASE COME HERE
AT THE TABLE [inaudible]
JUST.
AS CHAIR.
MISTER MEMBERS RAND MARTIN -- ON
BEHALF OF ANOTHER CREDIBLE AIDS
ORGANIZATION THE H. HEALTHCARE
FOUNDATION THE LARGEST PROVIDER
OF CARE AND TREATMENT OF PEOPLE
WITH HIV AND AIDS IN THE WORLD
WITH ONE POINT FOUR MILLION.
PATIENTS IN FORTY THREE
COUNTRIES -- WE WE SHARE THE
SENATOR CONCERNS ABOUT PRESS.
I'M WE ARE A LARGE PREP PROVIDER
IN CALIFORNIA WE'RE THE LARGEST
PROVIDER IN THE STATE OF FLORIDA
WITH THOUSANDS OF PATIENTS.
WE KNOW WHAT IT TAKES TO GET
PEOPLE INTO PREP AND TO MAKE
SURE THAT THEY STAY ON PRESS --
WE ARE WE ARE HAVE BEEN HAVE
EXPRESSED SOME CONCERNS ABOUT
WHETHER THE CLINICAL GUIDELINES
THAT ARE PART OF PREP -- ARE
ACCURATELY DEALT WITH IN THIS
BILL WE THINK THE SENATOR HAS
MADE PROGRESS IN THAT REGARD.
NO ONE'S BEEN TIME N THAT TODAY
BECAUSE I LOOK FOR TO SEE WITH
YOU MEMBERS LOOK LIKE.
WE ARE VERY TROUBLED ABOUT THE
CONTEXT IN WHICH PREP WOULD BE
PROVIDED TO A PATIENT.
IN NINETEEN EIGHTY SIX I WAS THE
FOUNDING EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
THE LIFE IT'S A LOT OF LIFE
WHICH IS MADE UP A LOT OF THE
PEOPLE IN THIS ROOM.
FOUGHT VERY HARD ON A NUMBER OF
POLICY ISSUES IN THE LATE
EIGHTIES ONE OF WHICH WAS HIV
TESTING BEING PROTECTED.
PRIVACY FOR THE PATIENTS.
DID NOT WANT PEOPLE EXPOSED THAT
THEIR HIV STATUS WAS EXPOSED
BECAUSE WE KNOW WHAT THE IMPACT
WAS GOING TO BE.
WE FOUGHT VERY HARD FOR THAT.
WE WERE SUCCESSFUL WE HAVE VERY
STRONG LOS.
THEIR CRIMINAL PENALTIES FOR
MALICIOUSLY DISCLOSING AN HIV.
TEST RESULT OR CIVIL PENALTIES --
FOR FOR VIOLATING -- THAT
DISCLOSURE PROVISION -- THERE
ARE PROVISIONS RELATIVE TO
PUTTING AN HIV TEST RESULT IN
THE MEDICAL IN A SEPARATE
ENVELOPE IN THE MEDICAL RECORD.
IN IN ORDER TO PROTECT THE
PRIVACY.
SO NOW WE ARE TALKING ABOUT
PEOPLE WALKING INTO A PHARMACY.
A WALGREENS OR CVS.
AT A FIFTEEN FOOT COUNTER.
THERE ARE TEN PEOPLE STANDING IN
LINE WAITING TO GET A
PRESCRIPTION. SIX PEOPLE BEHIND
YOU GETTING TOOTHPASTE IN THE
AISLE BEHIND YOU.
THE PHARMACIST AND THE PATIENT
ARE EXPECTED TO DISCUSS THEIR
HIV TEST RESULTS.
IN THAT PLACE.
THEY'RE SUPPOSED TO BE TESTED
DISCUSSING THEIR SEXUAL HISTORY
IN THAT PLACE.
IT'S THE WRONG PLACE TO DO IT.
THERE ARE THINGS THAT NEED TO BE
DONE TO IMPROVE ACCESS TO PREP
THERE IS NO QUESTION ABOUT IT.
AND THERE ARE SOLUTIONS THAT DO
NOT PUT PRIVACY AT RISK FOR
PEOPLE WITH HIV.
WE WE ASK YOU TO THINK ABOUT
YOURSELVES WALKING UP TO YOUR
CVS COUNTER.
AND WHETHER YOU WOULD PERSONALLY.
FEEL COMFORTABLE TALKING ABOUT
AN HIV TEST FOR YOUR SEXUAL
HEALTH. TO A PHARMACIST IN THAT
KIND OF ENVIRONMENT -- FOR THOSE
REASONS I WOKE I'M GETTING A
LITTLE EMOTIONAL BECAUSE I'VE
FOUGHT THIS THIRTY YEARS AGO AND
I DON'T WANT TO FIGHT AGAIN -- I
ASK FOR YOUR NO VOTE ON THE BILL
AT THIS POINT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES WISHING TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION PLEASE FEEL
FREE TO STATE YOUR NAME AND
AFFILIATION IF YOU WISH TO DO SO.
SURE MORGAN CAR ALL WITH THE
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL ASSOCIATION
WE REALLY APPRECIATE ALL THE
WORK THAT I THE SENATOR IS DONE
AS WELL AS THE COMMITTEE HAS
DONE.
I THINK THAT THE AMENDMENTS THAT
HAVE BEEN TAKEN ARE VERY
THOUGHTFUL AND LOOK FORWARD TO
READING THEM AND PRINT -- WHERE
WE CAN RECONSIDER POSITION THANK
YOU?
BRENT SPENCE WITH AMERICAN
COLLEGE OBGYN SIMILAR TO CMA WE
APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR AND THE
COMMITTEE WE'RE GONNA MINUTES WE
LOOK FOR LOOKING AT THEM TO
PRINT NO RECESS OPPOSITION AFTER.
WE SEE THEM THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS TO MAD
REPRESENT THE CALIFORNIA CHAPTER
OF THE AMERICAN COLLEGE OF MERCY
SOLUTIONS WERE IN THE SAME
SITUATION AS THE PREVIOUS TWO
SPEAKERS WOULD FORWARD TO
REVIEWING THE AMENDMENTS AND
CONTAIN A WORK THE AUTHOR.
THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS
THERESA START WITH KAISER
PERMANENTE A WE DID HAVE AN
OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED POSITION
ON THE BILL WITH SOME CONCERNS
ABOUT THE PREP PROVISIONS THAT
SOUNDS LIKE A LOT OF GREAT WORK
HAS GONE INTO THAT AND WE WILL
BE HAPPY TO TO REVIEW THE
AMENDMENTS -- I DID WANT TO
POINT OUTTWO QUICK THINGS
KAISER PERMANENT IS STRONGLY IN
SUPPORT OF EXPANDING ACCESS TO
PEPIN PREP WE HAVE PROGRAMS IN
OUR OWN PHARMACIES -- FOR THIS
EXACT PURPOSE SO WE JUST WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT THE AMENDMENTS DO
NOT.
UNINTENTIONALLY NEGATIVELY
IMPACT THOSE PROGRAMS THAT ARE
VERY SUCCESSFUL SINCE THERE
SOUNDS LIKE THERE'S SOME NEW
REQUIREMENTS FOR PHARMACY STILL
WANT TO LOOK AT THAT.
AND THEN FINALLY THE THE NEW
COVERAGE LANGUAGE -- TO GET AT
THE TO VISITLIMIT TO ENSURE
THAT THAT PLANS WILL ONLY BE
COVERING -- THIS FOR SIXTY DAYS
AND THEN I KNOW THE PURPOSE IS
TO DRIVE THAT PATIENT THAN TO
CARE AND WE JUST WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT -- THAT THAT'S
WORKABLE AND DOESN'T AND
INTENTIONALLY CREATE -- YOU KNOW
A BUMPY ROAD FOR THE PATIENT AND
HOW THAT WORKS BEHIND THE SCENES
I THINK THERE'S SOME NEED TO
MAKE SURE THAT LANGUAGE WORK SO
THERE'S NOT A DISCONTINUATION OF
COVERAGE AND OTHER COMPLEXITIES
FOR THE PATIENT THERE SO.
I KNOW THE PLANS WILL BE
INTERESTED IN REVIEWING THAT
LANGUAGE AS WELL AND HOPEFULLY
CAN WORK WITH YOU THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES WISHING TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE THEN BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS.
AT THIS TIME TO BEGIN WITH
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GLORIA.
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND THANK YOU
SENATOR WINNER OF FOR BRING THIS
BILL BEFORE THIS COMMITTEE I AM
PROUD TO BE A PRINCIPAL CO
AUTHOR -- WITH -- MISTER GIBSON
ON THE SUPPORT PIECE OF
LEGISLATION -- I WANTED
KNOWLEDGE THEY MISSED THAT YOU
TAKEN TO MOVE -- THE BILL I
THINK IN WHAT IS GENERALLY
POSITIVE DIRECTION AS A NOTED OF
ABOUT MY COLLEAGUES ON THE
COMMITTEE BY THE SPEAKERS IN
OPPOSITION WHO -- I THINK WE'LL
PROBABLY INVOLVED IN THEIR
POSITION AFTER ABLE TO TAKE A
LOOK.
MORE CLOSELY AT THIS ALSO WANT A
KNOWLEDGE OF THE DIFFERENCES OF
OPINION BETWEEN DIFFERENT
COMMITTEE CHAIRS -- WHICH IS A
FUNCTION OF YOUR POSITION I
THINK WE WE HAVE TO DO IS KEEP
THIS BILL MOVING FORWARD AND I
HOPE THAT EVERY MEMBER OF THIS
LEGISLATURE -- WILL BE COMMITTED
TO DOING THAT -- EN MASSE IT
WOULD JUST OBSERVE A REAL
IDENTIFICATION WITH THE PERSONAL --
COMMENTS THAT YOU SHARED WITH
THE COMMITTEE -- WHETHER THROUGH
PERSONAL EXPERIENCE A DIFFERENT
EXPERIENCE OF CLOSE FRIENDS --
THERE IS A PROBLEM HERE THAT
THIS LEGISLATURE CAN HELP FIX
AND THAT'S WHAT THIS BILL IS
INTENDED TO DO -- THERE'S BEEN
X. OUTSTANDING REPORTING LAST
MONTH OR SO NOT JUST ABOUT THE
ORIGINS OF THIS MEDICATION --
WHICH IS THAT WE ALL PAID FOR
ITS CREATION -- BUT THE LACK OF
ACCESS TO IT THAT IS HAPPENING
IN THE REALLY SORT OF COLLECTIVE
ANGER WE SHOULD HAVE IT THE FACT
THAT WE HAVE NOT COME FURTHER --
IN IN STOPPING NEW INFECTIONS
AND GIVING PEOPLE THE TOOLS TO
PROTECT THEMSELVES AND THAT'S
WHAT YOU'RE BILLS DOING -- SO I
WOULD ASK EVERY MEMBER OF THIS
COMMITTEE TO VOTE IN FAVOR OF
THIS BILL HELP US ADVANCE IT
THIS MAY NOT DIRECTLY IMPACT YOU
ALTHOUGH I WOULD ARGUE HIV IS A
CONCERN FOR EVERYONE.
IN THIS DAY AND AGE BUT THIS IS
ON BEHALF OF AS WAS MENTIONED
THE TESTIMONY THE THOUSANDS OF
CALIFORNIANS WHO DO BECOME
INFECTED EACH YEAR WE BECAUSE OF
THIS AND OF THIS MEDICATION
BECAUSE OF THIS TAX PAYER
INVESTMENT -- THAT SHOULD NOT
HAVE HAPPENED IT DOESN'T HAVE TO
HAPPEN AND YOU CAN VOTE TODAY TO
MAKE SURE THAT IT'S LESS LIKELY
TO HAPPEN IN THE FUTURE SO.
I KNOW WE DON'T HAVE I DON'T
BELIEVE WE HAVE A QUORUM AT THIS
TIME BUT I LOOK FORWARD TO
MAKING A MOTION TO ADVANCE THIS
BILL AGAIN COMMEND YOU SENATOR
WIENER FOR TAKING ON YET ANOTHER
DIFFICULT ISSUE -- BUT DOING IT
IN SUCH A WAY THAT I THINK IT
MAKES A VERY LIKELY OTHER WE CAN
CHANGE THE NARRATIVE HERE IN
CALIFORNIA AND HOPEFULLY CHANGE
THAT FOR ACROSS THIS COUNTRY.
WE KNOW THAT THIS SAVES LIVES --
IN THERE SHOULD BE NO DELAY IN
GETTING.
ACCESS TO MEDICATION THAT COULD
PREVENT INFECTION AFTER EXPOSURE
IN CERTAINLY NOT FOR THOSE WHO
WANT TO TAKE IT UPON THEMSELVES
TO PROTECT THEMSELVES.
FROM WHAT COULD BE A DEADLY
DISEASE -- THIS AT THIS SHOULD
BE THE EASIEST FOR FOR PEOPLE
ALL DAY AND I HOPE THAT THE
LEVEL YES.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM KIDDING MEMBERS AT THIS
TIME.
SEE SEE NO ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS AT THIS TIME SENATOR
WIENER DO YOU WISH TO CLOSE.
I YES I THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISTER CHAIRMAN I WANT TO THANK
GOD -- MISTER COREY FOR HIS
COMMENTS AND FOR WORKING WITH US
ON THIS BILL AND OTHER HIV --
RELATED -- ISSUES THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER -- SO I I SAYS I
DO WANT TO ADDRESS A COMMENT
THAT WAS MADE BY THE LOBBYIST
FOR THE AIDS HEALTHCARE
FOUNDATION -- IT'S VERY
CONFUSING TO PEOPLE SOMETIMES
WHEN THEY HEAR -- AN HIV
ORGANIZATION CON MEN AND
EFFECTIVELY ADVOCATE AGAINST.
OUR ADVOCATE IN OPPOSITION TO
INCREASE ACCESS TO AN HIV
PREVENTIVE IT'S VERY CONFUSING
TO PEOPLE WHO AREN'T AWARE OF
AIDS HEALTHCARE FOUNDATION
LITERALLY RUNS MARKETING
CAMPAIGNS.
USE USES HIV HEALTH CARE DOLLARS
TO RUN MARKETING ADVERTISING
CAMPAIGNS TO PERSUADE PEOPLE NOT
TO TAKE CRAP.
THAT'S WHAT THIS ORGANIZATION
DOES AND FRANKLY IT'S OUTRAGEOUS --
AND SO IN TERMS OF THE PRIVACY
CONCERNS.
LET'S BE REALLY CLEAR NO ONE HAS
TO GET PROP.
OR PAP THE PHARMACIST THIS BILL
AND STOP PEOPLE FROM GOING TO A
PHYSICIAN.
OR IN THE CASE OF PAT BUT THEY
WANT TO GO TO AN EMERGENCY ROOM.
THIS DOESN'T CHANGE ANY OF THAT
ALL IT DOES IS IT GIVES PEOPLE
AN ADDITIONAL OPTION TO GO TO
SEE A PHARMACIST AND SET.
PEOPLE ALREADY CAN GO TO THE
PHARMACIST TO GET WOMEN CAN GO
TO GET BIRTH CONTROL.
PILLS MORNING AFTER PILL.
THERE'S A ORAL MANY ASPECTS OF
SEXUAL HEALTH WHERE YOU CAN GO
TO THE PHARMACY AND GET WHAT YOU
NEED.
GIVEN THE CONDOMS CAN GET ALL
MAKE ALL SORTS OF SEXUAL HEALTH
DECISIONS IN THE PHARMACY.
IF THEY WANT TO OR THEY CAN GO
AND SEE A DOCTOR IN A PRIVATE
ROOM IN A DOCTOR'S OFFICE.
SO THE IDEA THAT BY GIVING AN
ADDITIONAL AUCTION.
THE PEOPLE TO MAKE IT EASIER FOR
PEOPLE WERE SOMEHOW INFRINGING
ON PEOPLE'S PRIVACY.
IS A COMPLETELY BOGUS ARGUMENT
BUT UNFORTUNATELY IS INDICATIVE
OF THIS ORGANIZATIONS DESIRE TO
TRY TO SUPPRESS.
ACCESS TO PROP -- I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND SENATOR
WIENER AGAIN OF ECHOING THE
COMMENTS OF OUR FELLOW
COLLEAGUES WHO HAVE.
MADE THEIR OBSERVATIONS CLEARLY
WITH RESPECT TO THE ADVOCACY
THAT YOU HAVE MADE ON THE POLICY
MERITS.
OF THE BILL BEFORE US HERE SEEM
AS SOME REALLY WANT TO THANK YOU
OF A WILLINGNESS TO WORK WITH US
TO HELP STRENGTHEN THE BILL AND
HELPING TO RECOGNIZE THAT THE
COMPONENTS OF THE ISSUE.
AS MOVES FORWARD CERTAINLY THE
INTENSE LEGISLATIVE INTENT TO
CONTINUE TO PROTECT INDIVIDUALS
IS PARAMOUNT AND WE WANT TO
SHARE IN THOSE EFFORTS.
SIMILARLY AS IT MOVES THROUGH
THE PROCESS WE WILL OF COURSE A
WORK WITH THE ASSOCIATED
PERSPECTIVE OF THE HOUSE TO
ENSURE.
A CONFORMITY ON THESE ISSUES A
MOVING THE ISSUE FORD -- AGAIN
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
CONTINUING THIS EFFORT WE
CURRENTLY A LACK OF CORM SO
WE'LL TAKE UP THE MEASURE WILL
BE A STEPS A QUORUM BUT AGAIN --
WE VERY MUCH APPRECIATE YOUR
ASSISTANCE IN THIS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
BUT THE MOVE ON TO THE NEXT ITEM
WHICH IS FILE ITEM NUMBER FIVE
SB FOUR TWENTY FIVE BY SENATOR
HILL.
SENATOR WELCOME YOUR BILL ENJOYS
IT DO PASS RECOMMENDATION ON
BOTH SIDES PLEASE FEEL FREE TO
PRESENT WHENEVER READY.
LET ME FIRST START OFF BY
ACCEPTING THE AMENDMENT
SUGGESTED IN THE ANALYSIS WHICH
WOULD STRIKE IN GOOD FAITH.
SB FOUR TWENTY FIVE REQUIRES
HOSPITALS CLINICS AND OTHER
HEALTH FACILITIES TO REPORT
ALLEGATIONS OF PATIENTS SEXUAL
ABUSE.
AND OTHER SEXUAL MISCONDUCT BY
MEDICAL PROFESSIONALS TO THE
APPROPRIATE STATE LICENSING
AUTHORITY WITHIN FIFTEEN DAYS.
AS BEFORE TWENTY FIVE CLOSES
LOOPHOLES THAT -- CAN ALLOW
SUBJECT OF REPEATED SEXUAL ABUSE
AND MISCONDUCT.
A COP COMPLAINTS TO WORK AT A
HEALTH FACILITY FOR YEARS
BECAUSE THE RELEVANT REGULATORY
BOARD IS NOT NOTIFIED BY THE
FACILITY OF THE ALLEGATIONS
AGAINST THE LICENSEE.
ALLEGATIONS OF SEXUAL ABUSE OR
MISCONDUCT BY DOCTORS AND OTHER
MEDICAL PROFESSIONALS MUST BE
REPORTED SWIFTLY TO THE
APPROPRIATE LICENSING BOARD --
AS YOU'RE ALL FAMILIAR WITH USC
AND DOCTOR TYNDALL SCANDAL WHERE
THERE WERE MULTIPLE COMPLAINTS
OF SEXUAL MISCONDUCT FOR DECADES
NONE OF THE PRIOR COMPLAINTS
WERE REPORTED TO THE MEDICAL
BOARD THIS IS WHY.
THE MANDATORY REPORTING WITHIN
FIFTEEN DAYS TO THE MEDICAL
BOARD IS ESSENTIAL.
WE KNOW THE HOSPITAL'S TAKING
CARE OF THESE ISSUES THEMSELVES
HASN'T WORKED.
JUST LIKE IT DIDN'T WORK FOR THE
LEGISLATURE WHICH IS WHY WE FIND
WE CHANGE THAT I'M HAPPY TO
REPORT THIS MEASURE HAS NO
OPPOSITION.
AND THE RECENT AMENDMENTS I ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE IN THERE ARE
WITNESSES HERE THANK YOU THANK
YOU VERY MUCH IF YOU IS JUST
KIND OF POP FROM MOMENTS SO THAT
WE CAN ESTABLISH A QUORUM.
LOW.
HERE BRO.
BLOOM [inaudible]
ARAMBULA CHEN.
CHAU.
CUNNINGHAM.
EGGMAN FONG GIPSON.
GLORIA GRAYSON.
HOLDEN.
IRWIN.
MEDINA MULLIN OBERNOLTE TANK.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE'VE NOW
ESTABLISHED A QUORUM.
BOTH FAST AND FOR SOME ROSE WITH
THE MEDICAL BOARD OF CALIFORNIA
THE BOARD BELIEVES THAT THIS
BILL WILL FURTHER OUR MISSION OF
CONSUMER PROTECTION.
AND MAKE SURE THAT THE BOARD IS
AWARE OF THESE ALLEGATIONS OF
THE BOARD CAN LOOK INTO IT
INCIDENTS AS A POTENTIAL SEXUAL
ABUSE AND MISCONDUCT.
AND WE'RE IN SUPPORT BY OUR
DRIVER THANK YOU VERY MUCH IT IS
NOBODY'S IS WISHING TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT.
WE ON MISTER CHAMBERS ALEX OFF
ON THE CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL
ASSOCIATION REALLY APPRECIATE
THE WORK OF THE AUTHOR ON THIS
MOVING TO A SUPPORT POSITION
WITH THE COMMITTEE MINUTES.
CALIFORNIA BOARD OF PSYCHOLOGY
IN SUPPORT.
ANDRE MCMILLAN REPRESENTING THE
BORDER COMPRESS ICKY.
CHIROPRACTIC EXAMINERS WE ARE IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
MEGAN ALL RIGHT ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL ASSOCIATION
REALLY APPRECIATE ALL THE WORK
OF THE AUTHOR ON THIS AND IT WAS
A PLEASURE TO WORK WITH YOU AND
WE WOULD RESPECTFULLY REMOVE OUR
OPPOSITION.
FOR TWENTY FIVE A GOOD MORNING
BREANNA CAM AND SPENCER WITH THE
CALIFORNIA DENTAL ASSOCIATION
ECHO THE COMMENTS OF MY
COLLEAGUE WITH THE MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION WE HAVE ALSO REMOVED
ARE OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED
POSITION THANK YOU.
ANY ADDITIONAL WITNESSES WISHING
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT CNN ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION SEE NONE
SENATOR.
I'M SORRY YEAH ANY QUESTIONS
COMMENTS AT THIS TIME.
SEE NONE SENATOR HILL DO WISH TO
CLOSE I WOULD JUST LIKE TO AND
AND I REALLY APPRECIATE THE THE
STAKEHOLDERS INVOLVED IN
PARTICULAR THE CALIFORNIA
MEDICAL ASSOCIATION FOR ACTING
AND WORKING IN SUCH GOOD FAITH.
WITH US IN CRAFTING THIS OF
FINAL OF DETERMINATION IN THE
PRODUCT THAT WE HAVE
RESPECTFULLY ASTRONOMICAL
MEMBERS THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH CENTER FIELD THERE'S BEEN A
MOTION AND A SECOND COMMITTEE
SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
SB FOUR TWENTY FIVE MOTIONS TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO COMMITTEE ON
JUDICIARY LOW THOUGH I PRO FOR
AYE ARAMBULA BLOOM.
THEN I CHEN CHEN AYE CHIU
CUNNINGHAM.
EGGMAN AND I FONG FONG AYE
GIPSON.
IT'S AN AYE GLORIA GLORIA AYE
GRAYSON.
GRAYSON AYE HOLDEN.
IRWIN AROUND AYE MCCARTY MEDINA
MEDINA AYE MULLIN OBERNOLTE TING.
TING AYE.
THE BILL HAS TWELVE THOSE WHO
LEAVE THE ROAD OPEN FOR
ADDITIONAL MEMBERS THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MISTER CHAIRMAN THANK
YOU MEMBERS VERY VERY MY SENATE
HILL WITHIN A MOVE TO FILE ITEM
NUMBER SEVEN WHICH IS SB.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
AND MEMBERS I'M HAPPY TO PRESENT --
SB FIVE SIXTY NINE I FIRST WOULD
LIKE TO THANK THE CHAIR FOR HIS
PERSONAL INTEREST IN HELPING ME
CRAFT THIS BILL.
AND WE DO ACCEPT THEM AND SET UP
AND SO AUTHORED -- I WOULD LIKE --
TO THANK ALSO AND SOCCER AND
HEAR FROM THE STATE BOARD OF
PHARMACY -- WE RECEIVED A LOT OF
INFORMATION ABOUT CHALLENGES --
DURING THE DECLARED DISASTERS
INCLUDING THE RECENT CAMP --
FOUGHT WILDFIRE.
DURING THE CAMPFIRE MANY
INDIVIDUALS WERE DISPLACED AND
SIGNIFICANT DAMAGE OCCURRED
INFRASTRUCTURE AND HEALTHCARE
FACILITIES ONE OF THE CHALLENGES
IDENTIFIED TO THE BOARD WAS A
LIMITED ACCESS TO PRESCRIPTION
MEDICATIONS INCLUDING CONTROLLED
MEDICATIONS.
LIKE PAIN ADHD DEPRESSION AND
ANXIETY TREATMENT MEDICATIONS
EXISTING LAW ESTABLISHES
REQUIREMENTS FOR CONTROLLED
SUBSTANCE SECURITY FORMS.
INCLUDING REQUIRED ELEMENTS MUST
BE INCLUDED ON THE PRINTED
SECURITY FORM.
BUT THERE IS CURRENTLY NO
EXEMPTION FOR THESE REQUIREMENTS
DURING A STATE A DISASTER.
ALSO UNDER CURRENT LAW BOARD OF
PHARMACY HAS THE AUTHORITY TO
WAIVE PROVISIONS OF PHARMACY LAW
IN A DECLARED EMERGENCY DISASTER.
HOWEVER THIS AUTHORITY ODDLY
DOES NOT EXTEND TO HEALTH AND
SAFETY CODE PROVISIONS.
IN ADDITION THE DURING A
DECLARED DISASTER MANY PATIENT
CARE AREAS OCCUR IN AREAS IN
EMERGENCY SHELTERS PUBLIC
SCHOOLS AND EVEN CHURCHES THESE
TRADITION ON TRADITIONAL MEDICAL
CARE SETTINGS MAY NOT HAVE.
ACCESS TO COMPLY AND CONTROLLED
SUBSTANCE SECURITY FORMS.
SB FIVE SIXTY NINE WILL FIX ALL
OF THIS.
BY CREATING A LIMITED EXEMPTION
TO THE CONTROLLED SUBSTANCES
FORMS.
REQUIREMENTS DURING THE INITIAL
PHASE OF A LOCAL STATE OR A
FEDERALLY DECLARED DISASTER.
SB FIVE SIXTY NINE HAS NO FORMAL
OPPOSITION IS PASSED THE SENATE
COMMITTEES ON THE FLOOR
UNANIMOUSLY TODAY WITH ME TO
TESTIFY.
AGAIN IN SUPPORT OF SB FIVE
SIXTY NUYS ANSATA GRAHAM WHO IS
THE ASSISTANT EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE PHARMACY
WE WELCOME HER TODAY.
THANK YOU ON BEHALF OF THE BOARD
OF PHARMACY AT LIKE TO THINK
CENTER TRISTAN FOR OFFERING THIS
AND I'D ALSO LIKE TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE CHAIR AS WELL AS
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR YOUR IN PLAY
AND MAKING THIS BILL EVEN BETTER --
THE BOARD IS A CONSUMER
PROTECTION AGENCY CHARGED WITH
REGULATING THE PRACTICE OF
PHARMACY AND SO IT'S WITH THAT
BASIC TENET THAT WE ARE PURSUING
THIS LEGISLATION.
THIS MEASURE WILL SECURE THE
LIMITED EXEMPTION FROM
CONTROLLED SUBSTANCES SECURITY
FORM REQUIREMENTS DURING AN
INITIAL PHASE OF A CRISIS OF A
DECLARE DISASTER WHICH IS REALLY
PROVIDING A BRIDGE FOR PATIENTS
TO ACCESS TO LIFE SAVING
MEDICATIONS.
I THINK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION REQUEST RIGHT BUT
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES WISHING TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING MEGAN ALL RIGHT ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION REALLY SUPPORT THE
BILL IN PRINT THAT WE WORKED ON
THIS ISSUE WITH THE SECURITY
PRINTER.
PRESCRIPTION PADS EARLIER THIS
YEAR AND THE PROBLEMS IN
IMPLEMENTATION AND REALLY
SUPPORT THE WORK THAT THE
SENATOR IS DONE ON THIS WE DO
HAVE SOME CONCERNS ABOUT THE
AMENDMENTS OFFERED IN THE
ANALYSIS.
AND THE HINDRANCE OF TO ACCESS
THAT WE BELIEVE THEY MIGHT RAISE --
SO WE'RE GONNA CONTINUE TO CHECK
OUT THIS BILL AS IT IT GOES IN
DIFFERENT WORK WITH THE AUTHOR.
THANK YOU.
HI THERE I'M MELINDA WILLIE AND
THIS IS SWEET PEA SHE'S A
LICENSE SERVICE DOG AND ALSO
REGISTERED THERAPY DOG WE DID
SEARCH AND RESCUE ON THE FIRES
FROM JULY THROUGH AUGUST.
UP NEAR MOUNT SHASTA AND READY
AND WE ALSO DID HELP ON THE
PARADISE FIRE WE RAN INTO MANY
PEOPLE WHO DID NOT HAVE THEIR
PRESCRIPTIONS COULD NOT GET
THEIR PRESCRIPTIONS.
IN AND ROTATING MANY OTHER
SURVIVORS TO MY HOME I WAS
DRIVING THEM TO PHARMACIES AND
TRYING TO GET THE MEDICATION AND
WE COULD NOT GET THE MEDICATION.
SO THEN WE WOULD GO DOWN THE
AISLES AT THE PHARMACY AND
TRYING TO FIND SOMETHING.
IN THE SHELVES THAT WOULD HELP
THEM.
IT WAS A VERY CHALLENGING
SITUATION TO SEE PEOPLE BEGGING
FOR THEIR MEDICATIONS AND NOT BE
ABLE TO GET THEM -- SWEET PEA
AND I SUPPORT THIS BILL A 100%
BECAUSE WE'VE HAD DIRECT
EXPERIENCE WITH PATIENTS NOT
BEING ABLE TO GET THEM IN THE
FAR SITUATIONS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL WITH THIS OFFICIALLY
SPEAKING SUPPORT SEEING THAN
ANYONE ELSE'S IN OPPOSITION SEE
NOTICES IN OPPOSITION ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS AT THIS TIME.
MISTER CHECK.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR ON WHICH
ONE OF THANK YOU OFFER FOR
BRINGING THIS LEGISLATION FOR
BUT ALSO WANT TO THANK THE CHAIR
IN THE COMMITTEE STAFF.
I KNOW THERE ARE SOME ISSUES
THAT -- ULTIMATELY WERE RESOLVED
BUT I WANT TO THANK YOU CHAIR
FOR THE COMMITTEE STAFF FOR
THEIR DILIGENCE IN THEIR HARD
WORK AND ALWAYS REGION OF
PROSECUTOR I'LL TO FIND COMMON
GROUND.
IS SOMETHING THAT YOU HAVE DONE
AND I BELIEVE THERE'S NO OTHER
CHAIR THAT HAS A ONE PERSON AT A
TIME OF ACTION SO THANK YOU SO
MUCH.
FOR YOUR DUE DILIGENCE ON THIS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
CNN CENTER SO DO YOU WISH TO
CLOSE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH APPRECIATE
THE OPPORTUNITY AGAIN -- MISTER
CHAIRMAN THANK YOU FOR YOUR
VALUABLE TIME IN HELPING US MAKE
THIS BILL BETTER.
AND I BELIEVE THAT IF WE PASS
THIS WE'RE GOING TO PROVIDE
ACCESSIBILITY TO PEOPLE THE NEED
THEIR MEDICATION SOMETIMES A
VERY TRYING EMERGENCIES AND WITH
THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH INTEREST ON
THIS BEEN IN MOTION AND SECOND.
THREE SIX EIGHT PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
SB FIVE SIXTY NINE MOTIONS DO
PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS LOW HI THOUGH I
BROWN. FOR AYE ARAMBULA BLOOM.
THE AYE CHEN.
CHEN AYE CHIU CUNNINGHAM.
EGGMAN AND WHEN I FONG FONG AYE
GIPSON.
GIPSON AYE GLORIA FOR AYE
GRAYSON.
GRAYSON HOLDEN IRWIN.
WHEN I MCCARTY MEDINA MEDINA AYE
MULLIN?
MULLIN AYE OBERNOLTE TING.
TING AYE.
SENATE HAS THIRTEEN VOTES WILL
BE THE ROLE OPEN FOR ADDITIONAL
MEMBERS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WILL THEN GO
TO FILE ITEM NUMBER THREE WHICH
IS SB TWO FORTY FIVE BY SENATOR
CHIANG.
CENTER CHAIN YOU HAD TWO BILLS
BEFORE COMMITTING THE FOR A
FIRST ONE IS -- ON CONSENT WILL
TAKE OF THE ITEM.
A LITTLE BIT LATER BUT THIS IS
THEN FILE ITEM NUMBER THREE SB
TWO FORTY FIVE THIS ENJOYS IT DO
PASS RECOMMENDATION ON BOTH
SIDES OF THE AISLE PLEASE FEEL
FREE 2% WHENEVER YOU'RE READY.
THANK YOU SO MUCH MISTER
CHAIRMAN COMMITTEE MEMBERS TODAY
I'M HERE TO PRESENT THE PETS FOR
VETS ACT THIS BILL WOULD WAIVE
ADOPTION FEES AT LOCAL PUBLIC
ANIMAL SHELTERS FOR MILITARY
VETERANS.
MANY OF WHOM SEEK EMOTIONAL
SUPPORT ANIMAL COMPANIONS TO THE
PUBLIC SHELTER SYSTEM.
CALIFORNIA'S HOME TO NEARLY TWO
MILLION VETERANS SOME OF WHOM
ARE COPING WITH PTSD OR OTHER
SERVICE RELATED MENTAL HEALTH
CONDITIONS.
THIS LEGISLATION WOULD BE
AVAILABLE TO ALL VETERANS IN
RECOGNITION OF THEIR SERVICE TO
OUR COUNTRY.
THOSE WHO TURNED ANIMAL
COMPANIONS COPE WITH PTSD AND
OTHER MENTAL HEALTH CONDITIONS
WILL ESPECIALLY BENEFIT.
ANIMAL COMPANIONS HAVE BEEN
SHOWN TO LOWER DEPRESSION LOWER
LEVELS OF SOCIAL ISOLATION AND
PROVIDE AN OVERALL GREATER
SATISFACTION WITH LIFE SB TWO
FORTY FIVE HAS RECEIVED
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT IN THE SENATE
AND IS CO AUTHORED BY THE CHAIR
OF THE SENATE VETERANS COMMITTEE.
WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
YOUR SUPPORT AND WITH ME HERE
TODAY IS A COUPLE ONE WHO SERVE
IN THE UNITED STATES MARINE
CORPS.
AS AN INFANTRYMAN FROM TWENTY
ELEVEN TO TWENTY FIFTEEN AND HIS
EMOTIONAL SUPPORT ANIMAL
COMPANION MISTER BUD.
AND GREG HAYES ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION VETERANS
SERVICE AGENCIES.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH UP TO THREE
MINUTES OF TESTIMONY IF YOU WISH
TO USE UP ALL OF THAT TIME.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS JAKE
ABOUT ONE OF MY CORPS VETERAN
SERVES IN TAKING THE TIME
ESTIMATES RANGE FROM TO DOES
LIVE IN TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN
DURING THAT TIME I DID TO COMBAT
THE PLANS THE MIDDLE EAST.
ONE TO AFGHANISTAN ANOTHER ONCE
THE AS YOU MAX AT FROM --
202-014-2015 WHERE I WASN'T US
THE THE US EMBASSY IN SANAA
YEMEN WE EVACUATED AT THAT TIME --
STAND TO DO DOESN'T SIDE OF THAT
IT WAS A CHAOTIC TIME WE'RE WE
DESTROYED EVERYTHING THAT WE OWN
AND HOW TO GET OUT OF THERE.
AND SO -- JUST TO GIVE A
TIMELINE FOR THAT AROUND
FEBRUARY TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN WE
HAD GONE THROUGH THAT WITHIN TWO
MONTHS OF THAT WAS BACK HOME AND
MEETING MY FAMILY AND GETTING
READY TO GO BACK.
TO GET READY TRANSITION OUT WITH
THEM TOO MUCH OF THAT.
I WAS OUT OF THE MILITARY AS
SOON AS I GOT OUT -- I DIDN'T
FEEL LIKE I REALLY WANT TO BE
HOME FROM SACRAMENTO BUT IT JUST
IT'S LIKE HOME TO ME ANYMORE AND
THE ONLY THING THAT WOULD KEEP
ME AROUND -- AT THE TIME I FIRST
WAS MY GRANDFATHER WHICH IS A
MAN WHO RAISED ME.
AND AROUND THAT TIME ALSO TO WE
GOT BUT AT FIRST I WASN'T TOO
EXCITED ABOUT HIM I DIDN'T
REALLY THINK ABOUT.
TAKING CARE OF SOMETHING ELSE
BUT GROWING ON ME AND SO ABOUT
TWO YEARS ACTUALLY TWO YEARS AGO
LAST WEEK -- MY GREAT
GRANDFATHER PASSED AWAY AND I
IMMEDIATELY WANTED TO LEAVE HOME.
I DIDN'T WANT TO BE AROUND
ANYMORE AND I JUST THOUGHT I'D
GET A MILITARY CONTRACTS IN IRAQ
IN THAT WOULD BE FINE -- TO GO
ON WITH MY LIFE BUT WHEN AS I
WAS TALKING TO MY WIFE ABOUT IT --
IT JUST CAME DOWN TO THE FACT
THAT WITH BUT I DIDN'T WANT TO
LEAVE HAVING FORGET ABOUT ME
BECAUSE I REALIZE THAT HE WAS
ACTUALLY MY FRIEND IS AXIS ONE I
CARED ABOUT YOU KNOW SOMETHING
THAT -- WOULD KEEP ME GROUNDED
AT HOME AND SO WE DECIDED THAT I
WOULD NOT GO OFF AND TAKE THAT
BACK OFTEN -- TO GOING OVERSEAS
TO WORK AND I WAS STAY HERE AND
GO AHEAD AND TRY TO BE A FAMILY
MAN AND MOVE FORWARD AND SO
TODAY -- MY WIFE IS ACTUALLY
PREGNANCY DUE IN OCTOBER -- I GO
TO SEX TE NOW
TO GRADUATE NEXT SPRING WITH A
BACHELOR'S IN HISTORY AND A
MINOR IN GEOGRAPHY HOPEFULLY
SHOULD BE -- WORKING FOR
CALIFORNIA SUMMER AND IN A LOT
OF WAYS I DON'T THINK YOU'D BE
POSSIBLE AT ALL OF WASN'T FOR
BUT HAVING HIM AROUND THE STREET
YOU SIX TICKETS TO GROUND AT
HOME AND IT'S NICE TO HAVE
SOMEONE THAT.
YOU DON'T HAVE TO HAVE LANGUAGE
TO EXPLAIN YOUR FEELINGS TOWARDS
OR ANYTHING LIKE THAT BUT YOU
KNOW THAT THEY STILL CARE ABOUT
YOU SO THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
THANK YOU FOR SERVICE DIGITAL
EDITION SUPPORT.
YES THANK YOU GREATLY.
CALIFORNIA SITUATION A VETERAN
SERVICE AGENCIES -- AND I'D LIKE
TO DEFER MY TIME TO MR BUT HI WE
JUST WANT TO ADD TO THAT --
STUDIES HAVE SHOWN THE VALUE OF
THESE PADS -- AND THEIR
THERAPEUTIC BENEFIT -- TO THE
VETERANS THAT -- WE SERVE AND WE
WOULD APPRECIATE YOUR AYE VOTE
THANK YOU THANK YOU THE DISH ONE
ASSISTANCE FOR SEEING NONE
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE COMMITTEE MEMBERS
WISHING TO SPEAK.
DOCTOR EGGMAN [inaudible]
WELL MA'AM.
OKAY.
IT'S MULLIN WILLIAMS WE P. AGAIN
WE ARE IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
WE DO A LOT OF OUTREACH TO
VETERANS AND DO PET THERAPY WITH
THEM WE ALSO WORK WITH THE
VETERANS ON THE FIRES -- THERE
IS SCIENCE BASED RESEARCH THAT
SHOWS HOW MUCH OF THERAPY ANIMAL
EMOTIONAL SERVICE DOG CAN HELP A
VETERAN -- IN THEIR BLOOD
PRESSURE GOING DOWN IN THEIR
PTSD BEING MEDICATED.
AND IT'S JUST A WONDERFUL
OPPORTUNITY FOR THEM TO HAVE
SOMETHING TO SHARE WITH AND CARE --
FOR TO TAKE THEIR MIND OFF OF
WITH THEIR OWN CHALLENGES MIGHT
BE.
AND WE'VE HAD DIRECT EXPERIENCE
OF THAT THIS IS A WONDERFUL
PROGRAM I WOULD LIKE TO ADD I
KNOW THERE'S A COMPANION BILL
THAT'S GOING TO BE COMING UP FOR
THIS.
THAT WHEN THE VETERANS TO GET
THEIR ANIMALS FROM THE SHELTERS
OR THE SPCA OR WHATEVER IT MAY
COME FROM.
THAT THERE BE SOME INFORMATION
ON WHERE THEY MAY BE GETTING
TRAINING FOR IT AND WHERE THEY
COULD GET SUPPLIES TO HELP THEIR
DOG WHILE THEY'RE TRANSITIONING
TO HAVE THE DOG AT THEIR HOME.
THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY WILL BRING IT BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE ON A DOCTOR EGGMAN
HAD A QUESTION.
THANK YOU I GUESS IS MORE OF A
COMMENT AND SPEAKING AS A DOG
LOVER.
I HAVE ONE THAT SHOWED UP MY
PORCH MONDAY IF ANYBODY'S
LOOKING FIRST CUTE LITTLE WHITE
DOG -- BUT IS IT ALSO HAS A
BETTER I'M NOT A COMBAT VETERAN
AND I MEAN I ALSO SUPPORT ANIMAL
SHELTERS WHO NEED THE FEES
OFTENTIMES TO BE ABLE TO KEEP
THEM GOING ESPECIALLY IN
COMMUNITIES THAT ARE FAR MORE
POOR -- SO I WOULD JUST MAYBE
THINK ABOUT AN AMENDMENT THAT IF
YOU ARE A COMBAT VETERAN MIGHT
BE APPROPRIATE TO WAIVE YOUR
FEES BUT IF YOU KNOW THERE'S A
LOT OF US OUT HERE WE'RE NOT
COMBAT VETERANS.
PROBABLY SHOULDN'T HAVE FEES
WAIVED -- AND I ALSO AGREE WITH
THE COMMENTS ABOUT BEING ABLE TO
LINK THE LINK SOME BETWEEN HOW
DO YOU TAKE CARE OF A SERVICE
ANIMAL HOW DO YOU GET THE MOST
BENEFIT FROM A SERVICE ANIMAL --
IS GOING FORWARD.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
AT THIS TIME.
CNN SENATOR TRYING TO WHICH TO
CLOSE.
I JUST RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THERE'S BEEN A MOTION
AND A SECOND COMMITTEE CITRIC
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
SB TWO FORTY FIVE MOTIONS TO
PASTOR PREPARATIONS LOW LOW AYE
PRO.
BROUGH AYE ARAMBULA.
BLOOM.
MY CHEN CHEN AYE CHIU CUNNINGHAM
CUNNINGHAM AYE EGGMAN AYE EGGMAN
AYE FONG.
FONG AYE GIPSON.
GIPSON AYE GLORIA FOR AYE
GRAYSON GRAYSON AYE HOLDEN.
IRWIN.
WHEN I MCCARTY?
MCCARTY AYE MEDINA MEDINA AYE
MULLIN MULLIN AYE OBERNOLTE.
TING TING AYE [inaudible]
THANKS.
THE BILL HAS FIFTEEN VOTES WILL
BE THE ROLE OPEN FOR ADDITIONAL
MEMBERS THANKS SO MUCH THANK YOU
VERY MUCH SANDERS CHIANG.
NOW MOVE ON THEN TO FILE ITEM
NUMBER EIGHT WHICH IS SB SIX
ZERO ONE BY SENATOR MORE.
SOME ARE ALL THIS HAPPENED IT
DOES ENJOY DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION ON BOTH SIDES
FEEL SAFE IS THAT WHENEVER
YOU'RE READY.
THANK YOU I AND FOR YOUR HELP --
SAM LIMóN LOW THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR A CABIN YOU AND YOUR
STAFF WORKING WITH US.
WITH THAT IN AND IF THE BILL'S
ALREADY BEEN MOVED -- MY
PRESENTATIONS ABOUT AN HOUR AND
A HALF BUT I'M JUST GONNA
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
DOWN.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES WISHING TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT -- GOOD MORNING
CHAIR AND MEMBERS MY NAME IS
REBECCA GONZALEZ AND I REPRESENT
THE NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF
SOCIAL WORKERS CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER WE REPRESENT
APPROXIMATELY TEN THOUSAND
SOCIAL WORKERS.
WITH THEIR DEGREE FROM AN
ACCREDITED SCHOOL OF SOCIAL WORK --
OUR SOCIAL WORKERS HAVE SEEN THE
DEVASTATING IMPACT THE WILDFIRES
HAVE HAD ON OUR CLIENTS AND AND
THE ON OURSELVES SOME SOCIAL
WORKERS HAVE LOST THEIR HOMES AS
WELL AS THEIR LIVELIHOOD.
DURING THE RECENT HAVE FIRES
CLINICAL SOCIAL WORKER BILL
DORSEY LOST HIS HOME IN THEIR
COFFEE PARK SECTION OF SANTA
ROSA AND HIS PLACE OF EMPLOYMENT
KAISERSANTA ROSA WAS CLOSED FOR
A PERIOD OF TIME.
AND MISTER DORSEY FACE THE
EXPENSE OF REPLACING HIS LICENSE
AND HE HAD TO SPEND TIME
TRACKING DOWN AND GETTING COPIES
OF CONTINUING EDUCATION UNITS
CERTIFICATES FOR HIS LICENSE
RENEWAL.
NOT ONLY IS MISTER DORSEY
STRUGGLING WITH THESE CHALLENGES
AS A SOCIAL WORKER HE IS USING
HIS TRAUMA AND GRIEF TO HELP
OTHERS TO RECOVER FROM THE
DEVASTATING EFFECTS OF THE FIRE.
BESIDES SOCIAL WORKERS MANY
OTHER FAMILIESHAVE LOST THEIR
HOMES AND THEIR BUSINESSES
PARADISE WAS A TOWN WITH MANY
SMALL MOM AND POP ESTABLISHMENT
THAT WERE DESTROYED BY THE
CAMPFIRE.
THIS BILL WITH WILL GIVE THESE
VICTIMS A BREAK ON OBTAINING A
NEW BUSINESS LICENSE OR APPLYING
FOR REPLACING A PROFESSIONAL
LICENSE.
SUCH AS A LICENSED CLINICAL
SOCIAL WORKER THIS BILL IS AN
IMPORTANT MEASURE TO HELP PUT
PEOPLE BACK ON THEIR FEET AFTER
A DECLARED EMERGENCY -- SB SIX
SO ONE WOULD PROVIDE MUCH NEEDED
FINANCIAL ASSISTANCE TO THESE
INDIVIDUALS AND THEIR TIME OF
NEED AND FOR THESE REASONS WE
SUPPORT SB.
SIX ZERO ONE AND ALSO I HAVE
ANOTHER WITNESS BOB SCOTT.
BUSINESS OWNER FORMER BUSINESS
OWNER FROM -- THE CITY A
PARADISE WITH ME TODAY.
OF GOOD DAY CHAIRMAN MEMBERS.
BOB MY NAME IS BOB SCOTT.
I AM NOT. FORTY YEAR PARADISE
TOWN RESIDENT -- RETIRED FIRST
RESPONDER.
AND HAVE BEEN.
VERY WELL CONNECTED WITHIN THAT
COMMUNITY AND BE COUNTY AS A
WHOLE -- MY WIFE AND
GRANDDAUGHTER AND I FOUGHT TO
SAVE OUR HOME AND THEN ESCAPED
WITH THE CLOTHES ON OUR BACKS
AND OUR ANIMALS ON THAT NOVEMBER
EIGHTH.
AND JUST WOULD LIKE TO
COMMUNICATE TO YOU -- IT'S QUITE
AN EXPERIENCE SIDE HAVING TO
START ALL OVER AGAIN -- BECOMING
FAMILIAR WITH THIS BILL -- I WAS
ASKED TO MAKE A STATEMENT AND I
REPRESENT.
A LOT OF MEN AND WOMEN LIKE
MYSELF IN THAT COMMUNITY.
THE TOP ARE STRUGGLING.
AND THIS ASSISTANCE WOULD BE OF
GREAT HELP. FOR A LOT OF
ROADBLOCKS IN SEEMINGLY
INSURMOUNTABLE THINGS THAT WE
FACE RED TAPE.
AND THIS WOULD.
MAKE THINGS A LOT EASIER A SMALL
MATTER BUT TO A GREAT THING TO
THOSE THAT ARE SURVIVORS AND ARE
DETERMINED. TO PRESS ON AND STAY
THE COURSE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES WISHING TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT NAME INFLATION
IF YOU WISH TO DO SO -- MY
KANDINSKY FOR THE CONTRACTORS
STATE LICENSE BOARD IN SUPPORT.
BRENT THE KAHLER CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION LICENSE
INVESTIGATORS THIS APPLIES TO
OUR MEMBERS IN SUPPORT EARNERS
PENDING.
ANSWER GRAND WITH THE BOARD OF
PHARMACY IN SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING ROBERT MOOCHER WITH
THE CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT CNN ANY
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC QUESTIONS
BEGIN OPPOSITION AT THIS TIME.
NO MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC WISHING
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM KATIE
MEMBERS SEE NONE SENATOR MORAL
TO WAS TO CLOSE AGAIN I THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR HELP AND
COOPERATION GRATEFUL FOR THAT.
AND JUST AGAIN I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AND I BOTH THANK YOU
VERY MUCH GENERAL THERE'S BEEN A
MOTION AND A SECOND TWENTY SIX
THREE PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
SB SIX ZERO ONE MOTIONS TO PASS
AS AMENDED TO COMMITTEE ON
GOVERNMENTAL ORGANIZATION LOW
THOUGH I THROW.
BROUGHT ARAMBULA BLOOM THEN MY
CHEN.
CHEN AYE CHIU CUNNINGHAM.
I AM I EGGMAN.
I MEAN I FONG FONG AYE GIPSON.
GIPSON AYE GLORIA.
AYE AYE GRAYSON.
GRAYSON AYE HOLDEN.
IRWIN -- AND I MCCARTY MCCARTY
AYE MEDINA MEDINA AYE MULLIN.
MULLIN AYE OBERNOLTE TING.
TING AYE [inaudible]
OKAY.
SIR THAT HAS FIFTEEN VOTES WILL
BE THE ROLE OPEN FOR ADDITIONAL
MEMBERS THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU VERY MUCH EMERALD.
WHEN THEN MOVE ON TO FILE ITEM
NUMBER TEN WHICH IS SB SIX FIFTY
FIVE BY SENATOR ROTH?
SENATE ROTH THIS DOES ENJOY DO
PASS RECOMMENDATION ON BOTH
SIDES OF THE AISLE.
PLEASE FEEL FREE TO PRESENT
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY
[inaudible]
OF AN I COULD JUST AS FOR AYE
VOTE MISTER CHAIR IF YOU PREFER
GREAT WONDERFUL THANK YOU VERY
MUCH ANY ADDITIONAL WITNESSES TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT.
IN CENTER WITH THE BOARD OF
PHARMACY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES BUSH'S
BEGIN SUPPORT TEAM THEN ANY
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC WISHING TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING THAT IT ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS.
SEEN SAYING NONE -- THERE'S BEEN
A MOTION AND SECOND COMMITTEE
SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
SB SIX FIFTY FIVE MOTIONS YOU
PAST APPROPRIATIONS LOW HI WELL
I BROUGH.
BROUGH AYE ARAMBULA BLOOM -- MY
CHEN.
CHEN AYE CHIU CUNNINGHAM.
I AM I A MAN.
WHEN I FONG FUNG AYE GIPSON?
GIPSON AYE GLORIA.
AYE GRAYSON GRAYSON AYE HOLDEN.
IRWIN.
WHEN I MCCARTY MCCARTY AYE
MEDINA?
MEDINA AYE MULLIN.
MULLIN AYE OBERNOLTE TING TING
AYE.
SIR THAT HAS FIFTEEN VOTES WILL
BE THE ROLE OPEN FOR ADDITIONAL
MEMBERS THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN MURS THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
GREAT THEN WE'LL HAVE A MOTION A
SECOND ON THE CONSENT AND THAT'S
AGAIN FILE I DON'T KNOW WHAT SB.
SIXTY FOUR ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR SB SIXTY FOUR MOTIONS
DISASTER PREPARATIONS LOW HI
THOUGH I BROKE.
BRIAN ARAMBULA BLOOM.
HI CHEN CHEN AYE CHIU CUNNINGHAM.
COMING AYE EGGMAN.
AND WHEN I FONG FONG AYE GIPSON.
GIPSON AYE GLORIA GLORIA AYE
GRAYSON.
GRAYSON AYE HOLDEN.
IRWIN.
WHEN I MCCARTY?
THE AYE MEDINA I THOUGHT MY BRO.
FOR NOT BURNING ARAMBULA.
BLOOM.
BUT MY CHEN.
CHEN AYE CHIU.
CUNNINGHAM.
COMING ONLINE EGGMAN.
AND WHEN I FONG FONG AYE GIPSON.
GIPSON AYE GLORIA FULLER AYE
GRAYSON.
GRAYSON HOLDEN.
IRWIN.
WHEN I MCCARTY?
MCCARTY AYE MEDINA MEDINA AYE
MULLIN.
MON I OBERNOLTE.
TING TING AYE.
THE BILL HAS FOURTEEN VOTES WILL
LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN FOR
ADDITIONAL MEMBERS.
IT IS A MOTION ON FILE ITEM OR
FOR SB THREE EIGHTY FIVE IS OUR
SECOND.
THE MOTION AND SECOND TO PASS
RECOMMENDATION COMMITTEE SIXTY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
SB THREE EIGHTY FIVE MOTIONS
PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS LOW ART WELL I
BROWN.
BLOOM.
BUT MY CHEN.
CHEN AYE CHIU.
CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM I. EGGMAN.
WHEN I FONG FONG AYE GIPSON?
GIPSON AYE GLORIA COR I GRAYSON.
GRAYSON AYE HOLDEN [inaudible]
IRWIN.
WHEN I MCCARTY?
MCCARTY AYE MEDINA.
MEDINA AYE MULLIN.
MULLIN AYE OBERNOLTE.
TING.
TING AYE.
THE BILL HAS FIFTEEN VOTES WILL
LEAVE THE ROAD OPEN FOR
ADDITIONAL MEMBERS.
AND AS WE WOULD CONSIDER WE FOR
OUR FINAL AUTHOR WILL GO THEN
DEFECTED TO FILE ITEM NUMBER
FIVE WHICH IS SB FOUR TWENTY
FIVE BY SENATOR HILL WITH A DO
PASS RECOMMENDATION.
SB FOUR TWENTY FIVE MOTIONS TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO COMMITTEE ON
JUDICIARY ARAMBULA.
CHIU CUNNINGHAM.
COMING UP BY HOLDEN.
MCCARTY.
THE AYE MULLIN.
HELLO MY OBERNOLTE.
THE BILL HAS BEEN FIFTEEN VOTES
WILL LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN FOR
ADDITIONAL MEMBERS.
THEN ON TO FILE ITEM NUMBER.
SEVEN WHICH IS SB FIVE SIXTY
NINE BY SENATOR STONE WITH A DO
PASS RECOMMENDATION.
SB FIVE SIXTY NINE MOTIONS TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS ARAMBULA.
REPLY.
TO CUNNINGHAM CUNNINGHAM I.
HOLDEN.
MCCARTY.
MCCARTY I OBERNOLTE OBERNOLTE I
SEVENTEEN VOTES WILL LEAVE THE
ROLE OPEN FOR ADDITIONAL MEMBERS.
FILE ITEM NUMBER EIGHT SB SIX
ZERO ONE BY CENTER MORRELL WITH
A DO PASS RECOMMENDATION.
SB SIX ZERO ONE MOTIONS YOU
PASSED AS AMENDED TO COMMITTEE
ON GOVERNMENTAL ORGANIZATION
ARAMBULA.
ARAMBULA I CHILL.
HOLDEN.
OBERNOLTE OBERNOLTE I SEVENTY
VOTES BELIEVE THE ROLE OPEN FOR
ADDITIONAL MEMBERS THAN FILE
ITEM NUMBER TEN SB SIX FIFTY
FIVE BY SENATOR ROTH WITH A DO
PASS RECOMMENDATION.
SB SIX FIFTY FIVE MOTIONS YOU
PASSED APPROPRIATIONS ARAMBULA.
ARAMBULA I TO HOLDEN.
OBERNOLTE ABILITY I SEVENTEEN
VOTES WILL LEAVE THE ROAD OPEN
FOR ADDITIONAL MEMBERS
.
THEN WILL -- WHILE WE'RE WAITING
FOR MEMBERS I SEE THE ARE FINE
AUTHOR CURRENTLY AS I'M WATCHING
THE SENATE TELEVISION THAT --
SHE'S CURRENTLY PRESENTING IN
THE SENATE EVAN ASSEMBLY
JUDICIARY SO WE'LL JUST GIVE A
FEW MOMENTS THEN -- FOR THAT'S
CONCLUDE.
OKAY AND THEN WE'LL JUST GO IN A
FEW A FEW ITEMS OUT FILE UNDER
ONE WHICH IS CONSENT.
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR SB SIXTY
FOUR MOTIONS YOU PASS
APPROPRIATIONS ARAMBULA.
ARAMBULA I TO HOLDEN.
OBERNOLTE OBERNOLTE I SEVENTEEN
VOTES.
FILE ITEM NUMBER THREE WHICH IS
SB TWO FORTY FIVE I SENATOR
CHIANG.
AS WE DO FORTY FIVE MOTIONS YOU
PASSED APPROPRIATIONS ARAMBULA.
THE REBEL I TO HOLDEN OBERNOLTE.
REALTY I SEVENTEEN VOTES.
FILE ITEM NUMBER FOUR WHICH IS
SB.
THREE EIGHTY FIVE SB THREE FIVE
MOTIONS TO PASS AS A MINUTE TO
APPROPRIATIONS ARAMBULA.
ARAMBULA I TO HOLDEN OBERNOLTE
OBERNOLTE I SEVENTEEN VOTES.
THE MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM
NUMBER FIVE SB FOUR TWENTY FIVE
BY SENATOR HILL.
SB FOUR TWENTY FIVE MOTIONS TO
PASS AS A MANAGEMENT COMMITTEE
ON JUDICIARY ARAMBULA.
RAMBLE I TO HOLDEN.
OBERNOLTE OBERNOLTE I SEVENTEEN
VOTES.
AND THE MOVIE ON THEN TO FOLLOW
AYE NUMBER SEVEN SB FIVE SIX
NINE BY SENATOR STONE.
SB FIVE SIXTY NINE MOTIONS TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS TO HOLDEN
.
IT MEMBERS IT AS WELL KINDLY
WAIT JUST A AGAIN -- ALL THIS.
OUR FINAL AUTHORS PRESENTING
WITH
.
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR SB SIXTY
FOUR MOTIONS DISASTER
PREPARATIONS CHILL. TO AYE
HOLDEN.
BUT IS.
EIGHTEEN ZERO FILE ITEM NUMBER
TWO SB ONE THIRTY NINE TO PASS
AS AMENDED TO COMMITTEE ON
HEALTH ARAMBULA.
WE'RE GONNA VOTING.
TO JULY HOLDEN.
OBERNOLTE.
OBERNOLTE I BUT SIXTEEN TO ZERO
FILE ITEM NUMBER THREE A THREE
TO FORTY FIVE MOTIONS YOU PASS
APPROPRIATIONS CHILL JULY HOLDEN.
BUT AS A TWO ZERO SB THREE
EIGHTY FIVE MEASURES DO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS CHILL.
JULY HOLDEN.
BUT IS EIGHT INTO THEIR OWN.
FILE ITEM NUMBER FIVE SB FOUR
TWENTY FIVE MOTIONS YOU PASS AS
AN ATTACHMENT AS AMENDED TO
COMMITTEE ON JUDICIARY CHILL. TO
LINE HOLDEN.
BUT IS IT INTO THEIR OWN.
FILE ITEM NUMBER SEVEN SB FIVE
SIXTY NINE MOTIONS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS CHU.
CHU AYE HOLDEN.
BUT AS A TWO ZERO FILE ITEM
NUMBER EIGHT SB SIX ZERO ONE
MOTIONS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
COMMITTEE ON GOVERNMENTAL
ORGANIZATION CHU.
CHU AYE HOLDEN.
BUT IS.
EIGHTEEN ZERO FILE ITEM NUMBER
TEN SB SIX THIRTY FIVE MOTIONS
DO PASSED TO APPROPRIATIONS
CHILL.
JULY HOLDEN FOR IS A
TWO ZERO
FREE HAVE DEEPER DAYS WHO YOU
HAVE FAVORED DAYS SOONER YOU.
HAPPY BIRTHDAY DEAR MY GIVES IN.
HAPPY BIRTHDAY TO YOU THANK YOU
NAY.
SENATOR MITCHELL WE'RE JUST --
AWAITING TIME AND CAN YOU CAN
APPRECIATE THAT NOTE I WAS WITH
YOUR COLLEAGUES IN THE ASSEMBLY
TO DISH.
AND IF YOU WOULD CALL THEM AND
TELL THEM TO STOP ASKING
QUESTIONS I KINDA GOT HERE
QUICKER YOU KNOW INTERMITTENTLY
AN OPPORTUNITY FOR WHAT.
SO WE WE DIDN'T KNOW WHERE IS IT
WHATSOEVER WE IN FACT WE SAW
SOME OF OUR COLLEAGUES AND CAN
APPRECIATE YOUR INDULGENCE IN A
SOME OF THE CONVERSATIONS BUT
NONETHELESS A WELCOME HERE.
TODAY -- THIS IS AGAIN FOR
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC WATCHING
THIS IS FILE ITEM NUMBER NINE SB.
SIX THIRTY NINE AND THIS HAS A
CHURCH RECOGNITION OF A HIGH
ADDED TO PASS RECONDITIONED
PLEASE FEEL FREE TO PRESENT
WHATEVER READY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NOT ASK MY
WITNESSES TO DO WHAT I'M ABOUT
TO DO WHICH IS TO CUT THEIR
TESTIMONY IN HALF IF NOT MORE SO --
GOOD MORNING MEMBERS OF LIKE TO
BEGIN BY ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS TO ADDRESS CONCERNS FROM
PROVIDER GROUPS AND CREDIT ISSUE
OR IS IT LIKE TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE STAFF. FOR DEVELOPING
THIS LANGUAGE IS A GREAT
COMPROMISE AND I THINK YOUR
DILIGENCE AND COMING UP WITH
THESE OPPER OPTIONS SENATE BILL
SIX THREE NINE WILL INCREASE IN
STRENGTH IN CONSUMER PROTECTION
SURROUNDING MEDICAL CREDIT CARDS
THAT ARE OFFERED TO PATIENTS BY
MEDICAL PROVIDERS.
WHILE CURRENT LAW REQUIRES
MEDICAL PROVIDERS TO PROVIDE
PATIENTS WITH BASIC INFORMATION
CONSUMERS ARE STRUGGLING WITH
UNDERSTANDING.
HOW DEFERRED INTEREST PROVISIONS
WORK -- AGAIN THE THE
WONDERFULLY CRAFTED AMENDMENTS
THAT WE ARE ACCEPTING FROM THE
COMMITTEE CONSULTANT I BELIEVE
REMOVE ALL OPPOSITION.
AGAIN WE'RE NOT SAYING THAT
CREDIT CANNOT BE OFFERED IT JUST
CAN'T BE OFFERED WHILE YOU'RE IN
THE DENTAL CHAIR ECCENTRIC
CETERA -- I WOULD LIKE TO ALLOW
MY WITNESSES TO SPEND OF THE
TIME TALKING ABOUT WHY THEY
THINK THIS BILL IS IMPORTANT.
AND WILL ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS IN
MY CLOSING IF THAT'S OKAY WITH
THE CHAIR WONDERFUL -- UP TO
THREE MINUTES IN TOTAL FOR
TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT PLEASE FEEL
FREE TO IDENTIFY YOURSELVES AND
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS JOY
DOCTRINA TURNING THE CENTRAL
CALIFORNIA LEGAL SERVICES
EVERYDAY LOW INCOME CALIFORNIANS
COME TO MY OFFICE.
ASKING FOR HELP WITH MEDICAL
BILLS THEY CAN'T AFFORD TO PAY.
MORE AND MORE OFTEN LATELY
THEY'RE ASKING FOR HELP WITH
DENTAL CREDIT CARDS.
THAT THERE ARE STRUGGLING WITH
I'D LIKE TO SHARE A FEW OF THEIR
STORIES.
LAST YEAR I MADE AN EIGHTY FOUR
YEAR OLD AND CAL RECIPIENT WILL
CALL IRENE.
SHE WAS TOLD BY THE DENTIST THAT
SHE NEEDED MORE THAN TWELVE
THOUSAND DOLLARS WORTH OF
TREATMENT AND THE DENTAL CAL
WOULD COVER SOME OF THAT.
IT WAS SUGGESTED THAT I READ
COULD MAKE MONTHLY PAYMENTS ON
THE REST WHICH SHE AGREED TO DO
BELIEVING THAT SHE WOULD BE
PAYING THE DENTAL OFFICE
DIRECTLY.
INSTEAD SHE WAS SIGNED UP FOR A
DENTAL CREDIT CARD WITHOUT HER
INFORMED CONSENT.
THE FIRST BILL REVEALED THAT
EVEN THOUGH SO FAR SHOULD ONLY
HAD HER TEETH CLEANED FOUR
THOUSAND DOLLARS HAD BEEN
CHARGED TO THE CARD.
THE CARD CAME WITH AN EIGHTEEN
MONTH DEFERRED INTEREST PLAN BUT
IN ORDER TO AVOID PAYING
INTEREST ON THE ENTIRE ORIGINAL
BALANCE SHE WOULD HAVE HAD TO
MAKE MONTHLY PAYMENTS OF MORE
THAN 25% OF HER INCOME.
A MAN LOCAL EDDIE WAS SEVENTY
FIVE YEARS OLD WHEN HE WENT TO
THE DENTIST WITH A TOOTHACHE IN
ONE OF HIS FEW REMAINING TEETH.
PRESIDENTE CAL RECIPIENT HE
COULD HAVE HAD ALL OF THE TEETH
PULLED AND FULL DENTURES PLACE
AT NO COST TO HIMSELF.
A DIFFERENT PLAN WAS RECOMMENDED
AND SINCE ANY HAD DONE TO CAL A
MEDICARE DENTAL PLAN AND A FORTY
DOLLAR A MONTH INSURANCE PLAN
THROUGH HIS DENTAL OFFICE HE
AGREED TO PROCEED.
AFTER HIS MOUTH WAS NUMBED AND
HE WAS HANDED WHAT HE WAS TOLD
WERE INSURANCE PAPERS TO SIGN.
A MONTH LATER HE RECEIVED A
DENTAL CREDIT CARD IN A BILL FOR
MORE THAN EIGHT THOUSAND DOLLARS.
IT TURNS OUT HIS PRIMARY DENTAL
INSURER HAD REFUSED TO PAY
ANYTHING BECAUSE NO PRE APPROVED
TREATMENT PLAN WAS FILED AND NO
CLAIM HAD BEEN SUBMITTED TO TEND
TO CALVET ALL.
IF SB SIX THIRTY NINE WERE
LOCKED IRENE WOULDN'T BE BILLED
FOR TREATMENT SHE WOULD HADN'T
RECEIVED OR HAVE TO PAY EIGHTEEN
MONTHS OF INTEREST ON THE
ORIGINAL BALANCE REGARDLESS OF
WHAT WAS LEFT ON THE CARD.
AND ANY WOULD HAVE BEEN TOLD THE
DENTED CAL WOULD COVER ALL THE
TREATMENT HE NEEDED AND HE WOULD
NOT HAVE BEEN ASKED TO
UNKNOWINGLY SIGNED UP FOR A
CREDIT.
CARD AFTER TREATMENT HAD ALREADY
BEGUN.
I HAVE MANY OTHER STORIES BUT
TIME IS SHORT.
ON A PERSONAL NOTE I KNOW THESE
CARDS CAN BE USEFUL BECAUSE I
HAVE.
ONE I KNOW BUT I KNOW WHAT MY
DENTAL INSURANCE COVERS I HAVE
AN INCOME THAT SUPPORTS REPAYING
THE BALANCES BEFORE DEFERRED
INTEREST BECOMES A PROBLEM.
AND I OPENED THE ACCOUNT FULLY
AWARE OF THE TERMS LOW INCOME
CALIFORNIANS DON'T HAVE ANY OF
THOSE ADVANTAGES AND WE NEED TO
DO WHATEVER WE CAN TO KEEP THEM
FROM FALLING INTO A TRAP FROM
WHICH THEY HAVE NO ESCAPE.
THANK YOU.
GOOD UP GOOD MORNING STILL
MOURNING -- MY NAME IS ALAN
BONUS FROM LAGUNA BEACH FROM
PRIVATE CITIZEN IN LAGUNA.
ON FOUR YEARS AGO I NEED TO
CONSIDERABLE WORK OVER THE
COURSE OF CONSIDERABLE DENTAL
WORK OVER THE COURSE OF TWO
YEARS.
ON IN CONSIDERING THE EXPENSE MY
DENNIS RECOMMENDED THE KERR
CREDIT PROGRAM OFFERED BY
SYNCHRONY BANK -- WHICH LOOKED
ATTRACTIVE AS EXPLAINED.
IF I MADE ALL MY PAYMENTS ON
TIME AND PAID OFF THE BALANCE BY
THE END OF THE PROMOTIONAL
PERIOD.
ALL INTEREST CHARGES WOULD BE
WAY AND THAT CERTAINLY WAS
ATTRACTIVE UNTIL I GOT MY FIRST
BILL.
I HAD A SMALL BALANCE AT THE END
OF THE PROMOTIONAL PERIOD AND
EXPECTED TO PAY INTEREST ON THAT
AMOUNT SO WHEN I GOT A BILL OF
ALMOST A THOUSAND DOLLARS ON
WHAT WAS A SIX HUNDRED DOLLAR
BALANCE.
I CAN FIGURE OUT HAS SYNCHRONY
JUSTIFIED THREE HUNDRED FORTY
NINE DOLLARS IN INTEREST ON A
SIX HUNDRED DOLLAR BALANCE EVEN
AT TWENTY SIX POINT 99% INTEREST.
IT TURNS OUT THREE HUNDRED FORTY
NINE DOLLARS ON THAT BALANCE
WOULD IT BE AN EFFECTIVE
INTERESTED FIFTY ONE POINT 7%.
ALSO I CALLED SYNCHRONY BANK AND
ASK THEM -- TO EXPLAIN THEIR
MATH.
BUT THEY TOLD ME THEY DO MATH
DIFFERENTLY AT SYNCHRONY SO
WOULD YOU.
ESTIMATE YOUR COMMENTS PLEASE.
YEAH THEY AND THEY SAID THE
INTEREST WAS CORRECT BASED ON
THE ORIGINAL BALANCE ON SO I CAN
UNDERSTAND HOW THAT COULD BE
BECAUSE I PAID MY MONTHLY BILLS
ON TIME AND I PAY DOWN THE
ORIGINAL BALANCE.
BUT IT DIDN'T MATTER UNLIKE SOME
OF MY OTHER CREDIT CARDS THAT
HAVE A 0% PROMOTIONAL INTEREST
SYNCHRONY HAD A UNIQUE
DEFINITION OF DEFERRED INTEREST
IN THAT VERY MUCH NEVER HEARD OF
THE DEVELOPMENT OF A SEATED OUR
TIME.
A AGAIN THAT'S WHY I WANT TO BE
VERY CLEAR IT UP TO THREE
MINUTES YES AND THANK YOU AGAIN
FOR PATIENTS FOR COMING TO
TESTIFY ALL THE WAY HERE IN
SACRAMENTO SO ANY ADDITIONAL --
ME TO USE WITH RESPECT TO THIS
IS A WITNESSES WHICH IS BEACON
SUPPORT [inaudible]
NOT LAST DAM IN CALIFORNIA.
WE'RE BACK EIGHT DOLLARS
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORKERS CALIFORNIA'S.
AND JENNIFER LAWRENCE WESTERN
CENTER ON LAW AND POVERTY HERE
FOR QUESTIONS AND I SPONSORED.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES ARE MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC WISH TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT.
SEE NONE ANY WITNESSES WISHING
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION FEEL FREE
TO COME UP HERE TO THE TABLE AND
AGAIN AN ALLIANCE DATA.
LINES DATA -- THIS COMPANY THAT
MANAGES NUMEROUS -- RETAIL
CREDIT CARDS AND CO BRANDED
CARDS -- THEY ALSO MANAGE ON
HEALTH CARE CREDIT CARDS AND
WE'RE HERE ON BEHALF OF THE
ONLINE STATE OF WE DO APPRECIATE
THE SENATORS -- WILLINGNESS TO
MAKE SOME CHANGES TO ADDRESS
SOME OF THE CONCERNS THAT WERE
RAISED BY THE OPPOSITION AND
APPRECIATE THE STAFF WORKING
WITH HER STAFF AND TRYING.
TO REACH SOME SORT OF COMPROMISE
BUT WE STILL THINK THE BILL --
NEEDS SOME WORK -- WE THINK THAT
ACTUALLY THE IT'S STILL A LITTLE
WORSE FOR THE DOCTOR THE
PATIENCE AND THE FINANCIAL
INSTITUTION THAT'S MANAGING.
OF THE HEALTH CARE CREDIT CARD.
REMOVING THE PROVIDER FROM THE
TRANSACTION FOR FINANCING.
YOU ARE ACTUALLY SENT SENDING
THE PATIENT OUT.
INDEPENDENTLY APPLY.
FOR AN EXTENSION OF CREDIT
WITHOUT FULLY KNOWING WHAT THE
CHARGES AND FEES ARE ASSOCIATED
WITH.
THE PROCEDURE THAT THEY'RE
LOOKING TO RECEIVE -- THEY MAY
ACTUALLY.
END UP APPLYING FOR MORE CREDIT.
THAN THE ACTUAL NEED FOR THE
PROCEDURE.
SO IF YOU'RE FULLY INTEGRATED.
AND YOU KNOW EXACTLY WHAT THE
PATIENT NEEDS TO KNOW ALL THE
CHARGES SO SO WITH THAT YOU CAN
ASSIST THE PATIENT IN PROVIDE AN
ON THE PLANE FOR THAT EXTENSION
OF CREDIT.
THEY WON'T BE GETTING ANY MORE
CREDIT THAN THEY NEED.
BUT WHEN YOU SEND THEM OUT THE
USE A NAP OR THE USE AN IPAD
THAT MAYBE WITHIN THE OFFICE --
THEY'RE JUST APPLYING FOR AN
EXTENSION CREDIT SO IF THEY NEED
ONLY FIFTEEN HUNDRED DOLLARS FOR
PROCEDURE THURMOND END UP
GETTING TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED
DOLLARS -- AS AN EXTENSION OF
CREDIT -- AND YOU WILL WE DON'T
WANT TO BE IN A SITUATION WHERE
THEY'RE GETTING MORE CREDIT
THAT'S NECESSARY FOR THE
PROCEDURE -- SO WE WOULD HOPE
THAT WE CAN CONTINUE THE
CONVERSATION WITH THE CENTER HER
STAFF.
WE THINK -- AT THIS TIME -- WE
WOULD STILL REMAIN OPPOSED TO
THE BILL THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBER SCOTT
COVERING HER BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA FINANCIAL SERVICES
ASSOCIATION WE SHARE THOSE
CONCERNS WE APPRECIATE WORKING
WITH THE AUTHOR.
THERE IS SOME CONFUSION FOR
EXAMPLE THE BILL REFERS TO
ACCEPTING -- CREDIT WE DON'T
KNOW WHAT THAT MEANS IF SOMEONE
HANDS THE OFFICE THE
ADMINISTRATIVE ASSISTANT.
THE IPAD.
DOES THAT MEAN THEY ACCEPTTHIS.
WAR IF THEY ASK THE OFFICE WHAT
IS THE AMOUNT OF THE PROCEDURE
CAN WE PUT THAT INTO THE IPAD
THAT THEY'RE FILLING OUT.
THEY DON'T DOESN'T SEEM LIKE
THEY CAN DO THAT TO MISTER
ALICE'S POINT SO SOME
INVOLVEMENT WAS SEEN BE
BENEFICIAL SO FOR THESE REASONS
WE REMAIN OPPOSED.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES WISHING TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION NAME AND
AFFILIATION IF YOU WISH TO DO SO.
JASON LANE CALIFORNIA BANKERS
ASSOCIATION ALSO OPPOSED.
BREANNA THURMAN SPENCER WITH THE
CALIFORNIA DENTAL ASSOCIATION
I'M JUST WANT TO SAY THAT WE
WORK REALLY CLOSELY WITH AUTHOR
THE SPONSOR AND THE CHAIR.
AND THE CAT COMMITTEE STAFF AND
REALLY APPRECIATE THAT
AMENDMENTS THAT ARE IN THE BILL
OF THEY'VE BEEN PROPOSED I THINK
THEY REALLY DO I WALK A FINE
LINE.
MAINTAINING CONSUMER PROTECTIONS
THERE AS WELL AS LIFTING SOME OF
THE BURDEN ON PROVIDERS AND
OFFICE AND CREATING A
IMPLEMENTATION TIMELINE SO WE
HAVE REMOVED OUR OPPOSITION
THANK YOU.
GARY COOPER REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF ORAL
MAXILLOFACIAL SURGEONS WE HAD A
POSITION OF OPPOSING LESS
AMENDED AND WITH THESE
AMENDMENTS WE DO REMOVE OUR
OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
MR MEMBERS TO MADDEN REPRESENT
CALIFORNIA SOCIETY OF PLASTIC
SURGEONS WE ALSO HAVE AN OPPOSE
LISTEN MANY POSITION WE LIKE TO
THINK THE AUTHOR THE SPONSORS
THE CHAIR IN PARTICULARLY
COMMITTEE STAFF WORK EXTENSIVELY
WITH US TO WORK THROUGH THESE
AMENDMENTS.
AND WITH THOSE WE ARE REMOVING
OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS CRISTINA TO KARA
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
VETERINARY MEDICAL ASSOCIATION
PLEASE TO REMOVE OUR OPPOSITION
THANK YOU TO MISTER CHI.
THANK YOU TO SENATOR MITCHELL.
WE CLARIFIED THAT YOU KNOW.
IF I'M APPLYING FOR REST THE I'M
NOT REST THE REST IS A DOG
SOMEWHERE.
CHRIS ROSE UP WE HAVE A
SYNCHRONY FINANCIAL IN CARE
CREDIT THANK YOU SO MUCH TO YOU
AND THESE CHEESES WORKED LONG
AND HARD INTO THE WEEKENDS THE
NIGHTS ON THIS BILL TO FIX IT
AND TO THE SPONSOR IN TWO AND
THE SENATOR WHO'S.
WORKED VERY HARD ALSO TO IMPROVE
THE BILL WE ARE REMOVING OUR
OPPOSITION JUST ONE SAY THIS
BILL IS ALSO GOING TO JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE NEXT WE HAVE NO IDEA
WHAT AMENDMENTS ARE IN STORE
THERE.
I'M TO ME HAVE TO REVIEW OUR
POSITION BUT AS FOR RIGHT NOW
WITH THE BNP COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS WE HAVE REMOVED OUR
OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
MALINDA WILLIAMS SWEET PEA AGAIN --
HERE IS MY CREDIT CARE CREDIT
CARD I'VE USED THIS FOR AS LONG
AS THEY'VE BEEN OFFERING IT I
THINK TWO DECADES.
OF BACK TO THE FIRES THIS SUMMER --
I WAS DOING A SEARCH AND RESCUE
AND I GOT HURT IN THE FIRE
SEVERELY I GOT A REALLY BAD
SINUS INFECTION EVEN THOUGH I
WAS WEARING A MASK.
AND HAD HEAVY METALS GOING INTO
MY SINUSES -- UNBEKNOWNST TO ME
THAT SINUS INFECTION WHEN INTO
MY UPPER JAW BONE AND I LEANED
OVER AN EXERCISE CLASS CLASS ONE
DAY AND HAD EXCRUCIATING PAIN
FROM THE FROM THE NECK UP.
THEY TOOK FOR DOCTORS TO FIGURE
OUT WHAT WAS GOING ON A DENNIS
TO PRIMARY CARE A NEUROLOGICAL
CHIROPRACTOR AN ADONIS IN AN
ORAL SURGEON.
EVERY ONE OF THOSE HAD TO HAVE
SOMETHING PAID WHEN I GOT TO THE
ORAL SURGEON HE SAID I CAN'T
WORK ON YOU UNLESS YOU PAY.
LUCKILY I SAID DO YOU TAKE CARE
CREDIT AND HE SAID YES I COULD
BARELY TALK I WAS IN SO MUCH
PAIN.
THEY WERE CONCERNED THE
INFECTION WAS GOING TO GO INTO
THE MENINGES AND INTO MY SPINAL
CORD AND CAUSE MENINGITIS.
I DIDN'T HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO
PICK UP THE PHONE AND CALL
FRIENDS AND FAMILY AND SAY CAN
YOU HELP ME WITH THIS MONEY.
I COULD BARELY TALK CARE CREDIT
WAS A LIFESAVER IN MY INJURIES
DURING THE FIRES.
IN ICE I DON'T KNOW WHAT THE
AMENDMENTS ARE.
BECAUSE I'M I'M A PRIVATE PERSON
NOT NOT PART OF THE COMPANY
SPEAKING -- BUT I REALLY VALUE
THIS AND I'M HOPING THAT THE
AMENDMENTS MAKE IT EASIER FOR US
TO USE.
BUT IT'S ALSO HELPFUL IN BAD
SITUATIONS SWEET PEAS HAD
EMERGENCY SURGERIES ESPECIALLY
ON THE WEEKENDS WHEN YOU CAN'T
GET SOME OTHER WAY TO PAY.
AND CARE CREDIT REALLY HELPS IN
THOSE AREAS.
PLEASE DO THE PROPER AMENDMENT
SO THAT PEOPLE LIKE ME AND
ANIMALS LIKE SWEET PEA CAN GET
THE EMERGENCY CARE.
CAN PAY FOR IT WITH THE KERR
CREDIT AND THEN FIGURE OUT HOW
WE'RE GOING.
TO BREAK UP THE PAYMENTS BEFORE
THE PROMOTIONAL.
IT IS UP I HAVE NEVER PAID
INTEREST ON THIS CARD AND I'VE
HAD IT FOR OVER TWO DECADES BUT
YOU HAVE TO BE MINDFUL OF WHAT
YOU'RE SIGNING.
READ WHAT YOU'RE DOING AND
PLEASE DON'T PENALIZE THE PEOPLE
THAT DON'T READ THE FINE PRINT.
BECAUSE THAT'S WHERE YOU GET IN
TROUBLE IF YOU'RE NOT A
RESPONSIBLE PERSON YOU MAY NOT
FOLLOW THE RULES BUT DON'T
PENALIZE US THAT DO.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES WISHING TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE ANY QUESTIONS
COMMENTS FROM COULD MEMBERS NOW
AT SEA ASSEMBLY MEMBER GRAYSON.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND THANK
YOU SENATOR MITCHELL FOR WORKING
WITH THE CHAIR AND STAFF.
ON THE AMENDMENTS -- THAT HELP
THE BILL AYE AYE MAY I SAY THAT
I SHARE YOUR PASSION -- FOR
CONSUMER PROTECTION SPECIALLY IN
THIS PARTICULAR AREA SO THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR BRINGING.
A MUCH MUCH NEEDED ATTENTION TO
A VERY VERY IMPORTANT -- THAT
IMPACTS LIVES BUT ESPECIALLY
ALLIES OF THE UNDERSERVED AND
THOSE THAT ARE IN MOST NEED IN
OUR COMMUNITIES.
AND I THINK WE'VE PROBABLY ONLY
STARTED TO SCRATCH THE SERVICE
AND MUCH MORE WORK TO BE DONE
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
DR GRANT.
I JUST WANTED TO ALSO THANK THE
SENATOR AND IF I COULD TO THE
SPONSORS OF THE BILL MY MOTHER
ACTUALLY USED TO WORK AT CC LS
AND MAKE NO YOU AND SO -- YOUR
ADVOCACY AND VOICE FOR THE
DISENFRANCHISES APPRECIATED AND
RESONATES WALLOP.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TESTIMONY AND
FOR THIS BILL.
IT DOES -- DRIVE A TOUGH
COMPROMISE AND I APPRECIATE THE
AMENDMENTS THAT YOU TALK.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AS A MEMBER
GIPSON.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH -- SENATOR
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND TWO
WITNESSES FOR COMING I WAS
UNAWARE OF THIS UNTIL -- I GOT
PRO APPROACHED AND SAT DOWN MY
OFFICE AND MADE ME AWARE.
OF THIS THAT EXIST AND CERTAINLY
APPRECIATE THE SENATOR PER ONE
FOR DOING YEOMAN'S JOB AND
APPRECIATE -- A COMPROMISE BEING
REACHED AND HOPEFULLY THAT --
THIS BILL COULD UP SALES FORWARD
AND I'M ALSO TRY TO MEET AND
REACH SOME OF THE OTHER ISSUES
THAT WAS RAISED.
BY THE OPPOSITION BUT THEY WERE
MOVING IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION
AGAIN ONE THINK THE CENTER FOR
HER LEADERSHIP -- MOVING THIS
BILL FOR EXCESS WHAT'S HAPPENED
IS TO MAKE THE MOTION THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BLOOM.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR OF THAT
AND THANK YOU FOR THE BILL
SENATOR MITCHELL YOUR WITNESS
WAS -- BEFORE HE HAD CUT ITS
COMMON SHORT WAS IDENTIFYING AN
ISSUE.
OF THAT I FIND INTERESTING AND
THAT IS I THINK THE NORM WITH --
A CREDIT CARD.
IS THAT INTEREST IS BASED ON THE
UNPAID BALANCE RIGHT THAT A
CRUISE OVER THE COURSE OF
WHATEVER TIME YOU HAVE THE CARD
EXACTLY.
IN THIS CASE WITH THESE CARDS --
YOUR YOU PAY NO INTEREST -- FOR
CERTAINLY.
YES IDENTIFIED YET AND THEN
INTEREST IS A CRUDE ON THE ARE
YOU YOU PAY EVEN IF YOU'VE PAID
IT DOWN -- IF YOU HAVEN'T
COMPLETED PAYING DOWN THE
INITIAL BALANCE YOU OWE INTEREST
ON THE ENTIRE AMOUNT EXACTLY --
I WOULD IMAGINE THAT EVEN FOR
THOSE PEOPLE WHO ARE SAVVY
ENOUGH TO READ THE FINE PRINT.
THAT THAT IS.
WOULD GENERALLY COMES A SURPRISE
IT'S COUNTERINTUITIVE YEAH --
BECAUSE IT'S WHAT'S COUNTER
EXPERIENCE YES -- YEAH AND AND
COUNTER INTUITIVE.
SO HOW DOES THE BILL ADDRESS
THAT ISSUE.
SO THE WAY THE BUILD ADDRESSES
THAT CURRENTLY WITH A COMPROMISE
IS PRODUCTS THAT PROVIDERS ARE
PROCESSING APPLICATIONS FOR IN
OFFICE CAN NO LONGER HAVE THAT
PROVISION.
THEY MAY STILL HAVE A 0%
INTRODUCTORY PERIOD BUT AFTER
THAT INTERESTS ME ONLY BE
CHARGED ON THE REMAINING BALANCE.
SERVER THAT HOWEVER PRODUCTS CAN
STILL CONTINUE ON THE MARKET
THAT HAVE A DEFERRED INTEREST
PROVISION BUT CONSUMERS NEED TO
SIGN UP FOR THOSE OUTSIDE OF THE
OFFICE.
BECAUSE MR BLOOM YOU KNOW WHAT
WE WERE CONCERNED ABOUT AS I
THINK THE WITNESS TALKED ABOUT
SHE WAS FORTUNATE SHE'D HAD A
CARE.
CARD FOR TWO DECADES PRIOR TO BE
IN IN ANY EMERGENCY DENTAL
SITUATION -- OUR CONCERN IS WHEN
YOU'RE IN THE IN THE MIDDLE OF
AN EMERGENCY DENTAL SITUATION
AND YOU ARE HANDED DOCUMENTS TO
READ IN TWO FONT -- WITH A
TOOTHACHE IN THE DENTAL CHAIR.
I DON'T KNOW ABOUT YOU BUT
OUTSIDE ANYTHING FOR THE PAIN TO
STOP IN FOR THE TREATMENT TO
BEGIN.
AND SO THAT'S WHY IT'S THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN YOUR
EXPERIENCE IF YOU'RE IN THE
MEDICAL OFFICE VERSES IF YOU
APPLY SEPARATELY BECAUSE WE WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT PEOPLE.
ARE IN THE RIGHT SPACE OF MIND
TO BE ABLE TO UNDERSTAND FUND
THEM FUNDAMENTALLY WHAT THE
CREDIT CARD COMPANY --
REQUIREMENTS REALLY ARE SO
THAT'S WHY THE DIFFERENCE IN
EXPERIENCE IN THE TWO DIFFERENT
SETTINGS [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
AT THIS TIME.
SEEING NONE SENATOR MITCHELL TO
WAS TO CLOSE I WOULD JUST VERY
BRIEFLY ACKNOWLEDGE -- SOME OF
THE OPPOSITION THE CAME TO THE
TABLE TO TALK ABOUT PATIENTS YOU
KNOW -- BEING MADE FULLY AWARE
OF CHARGES I THINK YOU KNOW I
EXPERIENCE WHAT WE'VE HEARD FROM
A LEGAL AID REPRESENTATIVES IS
YOU KNOW SOMETIMES PEOPLE HAVE
NOT BEEN MADE FULLY AWARE OF
CHARGES WHILE THEY'RE IN THE
CHAIR.
NOR HAVE THEY BEEN MADE FULLY
AWARE OF WHAT DENTAL CALAR OR
THEIR INSURANCE WOULD ACTUALLY
COVER AND SO PART OF THIS BILL
WHICH IS FUNDAMENTALLY A
CONSUMER PROTECTION B. L. IS TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE -- RIDING
IN LANGUAGE -- THAT IS NOT
COUNTER EXPERIENCE CHILL -- THAT
CAN BE UNDERSTOOD BY THE PERSON
WHEREVER THEY ARE IN EITHER IN
THE MEDICAL OFFICE OR APPLYING
SEPARATELY AND ALSO MAKE SURE
THAT PEOPLE ARE INFORMED FULLY
OF WHAT THEIR INSURANCE COVERS
AND WHAT THOSE FULL CHARGES ARE
WE ARE ALSO CONCERNED.
AND THE MINUTES CLEAR FIGHT WITH
THE EXCEPTION OF ORTHODOX YEAH
THAT YOU'RE NOT CHARGED -- FOR A
FULL BATTERY A FULL TREATMENT
SERVICES BEFORE RECEIVING THEM --
AND SO THOSE ARE ALL THINGS THAT
THE BILL'S ATTEMPTING TO ADDRESS
AGAIN HATS OFF TO THE COMMITTEE
CONSULTANT FOR WORKING VERY HARD
TO COME UP WITH THIS COMPROMISE
LANGUAGE.
ALL AND I ASK FOR AND I THOUGHT.
WONDERFUL THANK YOU VERY MUCH
SENATOR MITCHELL THIS DOES ENJOY
DO PASS RECOMMENDATION AND
SIMILARLY WE LIKE TO THANK YOU
IN YOUR OFFICE ALL.
OF FOR WORKING WITH US TO
ACCOMMODATE MANY THEN THE
VARIOUS MOVING PIECES WHILE ALSO
MAINTAINING THE LEGISLATIVE
INTENT OF CONSUMER PROTECTION
THAT WE ALSO SHARE WITH YOU AS
WELL TO SOAK IN.
A CRUISE TO YOU AND YOUR OFFICE
AS WELL AND OTHER STAKEHOLDERS
SO THIS DOES ENJOY DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION HAS BEEN IN
MOTION AND A SECOND COMMITTEE
SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
SB SIX THIRTY NINE MOTIONS TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO COMMITTEE ON
JUDICIARY LOW THE HIGH PRO
ARAMBULA.
REPLY BLOOM.
BUT MY CHEN.
GEN NOW CHAIR TO AYE COMING UP
[inaudible]
EGGMAN [inaudible]
FONG.
I'M NOT GOING GIPSON.
GIPSON AYE GLORIA.
GRAY AYEGRAYSON.
GRAYSON AYE HOLDEN.
HOLDEN AYE IRWIN.
WHEN I MCCARTY?
MCCARTY AYE MEDINA MEDINA AYE
MULLIN MULLIN AND OBERNOLTE.
OBERNOLTE AYE TING.
TING AYE. FORTY ONE THAT BILL IS
OUT THANK YOU VERY VERY NICE AND
I APPRECIATE YOUR INDULGENCE Và
WAITING FOR ME ABSOLUTELY THANK
YOU VERY MUCH -- MEMBERS WILL
JUST GO THROUGH -- AND THE A
FINAL -- THEY BILLS BEING HEARD
AND FOLLOW ORDERS SO WE CAN WITH
CONSENT.
CONSENT CALENDAR SB SIXTY FOUR
MOTIONS YOU PASTOR APPRECIATION
HOLDEN.
HOLDEN AYE. NINETEEN ZERO THAT
IS OUT FILE ITEM NUMBER TWO SB.
ONE FIFTY NINE MATCHES TO PASS
AS AN ADDED TO COMMITTEE ON
HEALTH HOLDEN.
HELLO HI. SEVENTEEN ZERO THAT
BILL IS OUT FILE ITEM NUMBER
THREE SB TWO FORTY FIVE I CENTER
CHIANG.
MOTIONS YOU PASTOR
APPROPRIATIONS HOLDEN.
HOLD AYE. NINETEEN IS THERE THE
BILL'S OUT.
FILE I'M NUMBER SEVEN SB FIVE
SIX NINE BY SENATOR STONE.
BUT AS YOU PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS HOLD ON HOLD ON I
NINETEEN IS THERE THE BILL IS
OUT FILE ITEM NUMBER NINE WHICH
IS SB.
SIX ZERO ONE I'M SORRY OF FILE
ITEM OR SEVEN OF I EIGHT FILE I
NUMBER EIGHT SB SIX OR ONE BY
CENTER MORAL.
WHICH IS THE PAST AS AMENDED
COMMITTEE ON GOVERNMENTAL
ORGANIZATION HOLD ON HOLD ON I
NINETEEN IS THERE THE BILL'S OUT
FILE ITEM NUMBER NINE SB SIX
THIRTY NINE BY SENATOR MITCHELL.
QUESTIONS ABOUT AS AMENDED
COMMITTEE ON JUDICIARY BRO.
AND FINALLY FILE AND THE NUMBER
TEN SB SIX FIFTY FIVE BY SENATOR
ROTH.
MOTIONS YOU PASTOR.
HOLDEN HOLDEN AYE. NINETEEN ZERO
THE BILL WITHOUT.
THANK YOU WHERE YOU'RE AT